folks I don't have any pink cards
I don't have a representative
with a pink card to introduce the bill I
foreign
you could just get those to me quickly
and
have to check my email someone wants to
uh no we'll let the representative uh
introduce his bill first
morning everyone thank you for being
here
no more yeah
hey everybody all set to go
open the hearing on House Bill 182
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the labor committee
um this bill is very similar to a bill
that was passed
last year by the house uh on a Voice
vote
and I'm reintroducing it for some reason
it died in the Senate I have not been
able to find out why
but it is also part of the ad hoc study
on Recruitment and Retention that was uh
formed by commissioner Quinn last year
and what we can do to help
recruit and retain volunteer
firefighters
and volunteer EMS people
volunteers are at the heart and soul of
many of our communities
and anything that we can do to make it
better for them it's better for our
communities
it saves our communities money
and it provides a cohesive building of
the community
I'm not going to talk long on it the
bill is very simple
um
it prohibits
harassment for a firefighter or a
volunteer EMS person who leaves work
um
there is a similar provision in 153 a17
that allows volunteer EMS people to be
late for work and cannot be reprimanded
not exactly the same but very very
similar and that's been on the books
so
I guess what I'm saying is
we anything that we can do
to improve the Recruitment and Retention
of volunteer fireman firefighters be
careful and EMS Personnel would be very
beneficial not only to those individuals
but to the community at large I know
when our neighboring town of Sunapee
they're looking to put on two full-time
people
and that cost is going to be
north of 150 to 175 thousand dollars
so I'm going to just leave it on some
simple things on here somebody asked me
about statistics how often do we have
problems
it's not the type of thing that somebody
files a complaint if they've been
harassed because if they're being
harassed they don't want to get harassed
anymore by their supervisor so there
aren't a lot of
um statistics out there to say this
somebody spoke to me
recently and suggested that this would
be part of a trial period and I'd be
willing to accept an amendment to Sunset
this after three or four years
to see whether it does help recruitment
and retention
with that I'm here to answer questions
and hope that you will take 182
thank you representative are there any
I have one for you what is the standard
protocol right now or most employers
when it comes to volunteer fire and EMS
do they
um because you have here that no such
employer shall be required to compensate
any employee for the period is that
pretty much what happens right now
um they're just no not paid for those
hours most of them are paid for those
hours that I know of again there's not a
lot of statistics on it but I know uh
one of our bigger employers Storm Ruger
they uh
they compensate their people
okay next question
um
if I might have a follow-up Mr Bush here
um approximately how many volunteer
firefighters do you believe there are in
gonna ask me that for just a minute the
uh
four agencies
and I'd have to get back to what that's
remembered it's in this recruitment in
retention uh package but I'm not
prepared to answer it and some throw and
waste your time but I will get that
answer no worries yes please provide
that after we have a few more people
testify
are the other questions representative
attitude
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
um it's it's not a question about the
bill necessarily could we or could I at
least get a copy of that um Recruitment
and Retention information I'd be very
interested to see it uh in considering
this bill
I'm sorry what was the
could I get a copy of that Recruitment
and Retention uh packet that you have
I'd be interested in seeing that
information when considering the bill
yep
yes if you could get that to me I'll
make sure we get that to everyone I'll
get that to you
it was a commission that was put
together by commissioner Quinn of the
Department of Safety it had
11 or 12 members throughout the state
and they came up with a whole series of
findings and recommendations
I will get that to you and and that bill
on the fire on the EMS people
and you said you would be agreeable to a
two-year sunset
uh two or three I don't know whether you
want to go through a whole budgeting
career but whatever works for your
committee
um we're looking at that on the uh same
problem we have over at the fire academy
is getting
um
instructors and retired instructors who
are the best type to have and they're
having problems with the uh retirement
fund so we're putting a three-year
sunsharana
any other questions for the presenter
seeing none thank you representative
thank you very much and I'll get you uh
oh I'm sorry I'm representative there is
a question representative thank you uh
I'm actually a retired firefighter out
of Manchester and there is currently a
group as I understand that's meeting at
the Academy relative to the future of
the employment picture for firefighters
uh in general uh as we're going to say
so I think a tough time recruiting
firefighters in general
um are you guys participating uh at all
in those those discussions
uh I am not I believe our chief is uh
he's uh one of the presidents of the
firefighters Association so he's
involved in those discussions good thank
you
thank you and I will get you those two
things thank you representative thank
you
I have a pink card from Thomas Greene uh
Mr Green I'm just I received an email
that this Mr McAllister
John McAllister wants to speak and
because he has other hearings Mr
McAllister
finish
well I'm going to have Mr Green at this
um
representing the Federation uh I'll use
nhsfa
my acronyms very well on that one thank
you welcome to the labor committee Mr
chairman thank you Representatives thank
you my name is Thomas Green I'm the
president of the New Hampshire State
Firemen's Association uh we're the
oldest Firemen's Association in the
state we're actually enacted by the
general legislature back in 1899 a few
years ago we support House Bill 182. uh
I've been a firefighter volunteer
firefighter since 1977. I'm still active
EMT firefighter on Bedford fire
department one of the few call Personnel
are still left but we support this
because we're really interested in the
recruitment retention issues with the
state we're actively working with the
recruitment retention program that was
put together by commissioner Quinn we
have Representatives on that board as
well our objective is to make sure that
we can recruit and retain it's a
national not a national crisis but it's
a sliding scale on people volunteering
for fire departments and when you get
North on a notch most of the Departments
are volunteering call we don't have
people banging on the doors to get into
the fire departments the career
departments have a very short list of
firefighters who are coming to the
Firehouse so we're trying to recruit and
retain not only career but also call
volunteer with a small Department if
there's maybe eight ten firefighters on
the department now to to run a a call is
very difficult whereas 20 30 years ago
there was 30 or 40 firefighters on a
fire department on the volunteer
department so we find this bill is
important to give as much ammunition to
our volunteer and call Firefighters that
they respond to a call an emergency if
it's late at night three in the morning
they say well I got to get up and got to
get to work by six o'clock or I'm going
to not have a good time at work we don't
want to have them have that fear if they
can have a little bit of insurance so to
speak that they have that the state has
their back that the business has their
back that they're not going to be just
discipline for showing up an hour too
late to help out their Community to help
out their calendars times have changed
businesses have changed businesses
aren't local to the community so they
may not understand so we'd like to give
our volunteers and call Firefighters as
much
relief as possible it may not sound like
much there may not be a lot of
disciplines but it only takes one and we
want to make sure that we support our
firefighters to answer some questions if
you're looking for the Recruitment and
Retention information if you go to our
website
nhsfa.org we have it on our website you
can download it uh it's a it's a good
program
also for the amount of firefighters we
believe there's over 5 000 firefighters
in the state 1500 of which are career so
that would leave uh about 3 500
volunteer on-call firefighters we're
trying to get those numbers a little
more accurate by having people uh Fire
Chiefs submit their information each
year but that's about the number we have
it's about a drastic change from about
10 years ago where we had over 7 000
firefighters in the state so people
aren't volunteering like they used to
and some of these they go to Pittsburgh
you go to Freedom you go all over the
state north of the Notch and or north of
the lakes and there's not as many
volunteer on-call firefighters we're
trying to do as much as we can for the
communities because these are your homes
and your your towns and your roadways
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions for Mr Green
Mr Vice chairman thank you Mr chairman
when this bill was before us last year I
had sitting to my right a representative
who flies an airplane for a living
and I asked him what would happen if he
had a flight at 9am and he called and he
said you know what I'm not going to make
it I need to hold that flight a couple
hours
it wouldn't work for him and isn't that
the case that there are some
employers who are very accommodating to
volunteer firefighters and other
employers where the model really just
doesn't work
and does a one-size-fits all law
is that
will that cause a problem for certain
types of employment
well
I think that would be based upon a
choice of the individual if they chose
not to go because they have a doctor has
a surgery a pilot has a flight that's
their choice not to go but if they're
out on a call and they show up late to
work I mean you know if they if they
have to leave the call they leave the
call that's up to them that's a as the
firefighter but if they show up to work
and they're late and they get
disciplined
we're just looking to support our
Personnel not penalize the business
I hope that answers your question
origin of attitude thank you Mr chairman
um following up on the previous question
um in the hypothetical that you laid out
if a fire happens at 3am
and a volunteer firefighter is called
and they say well you know I have work
in the morning I can't really get up
there the fire is not going to wait
either correct that is true thank you
uh Mr Green uh
so I was a Manchester firefighter you're
in Bedford so thank you for your service
yeah make sure you know where my house
is in case you're doing mutually we're
second to there yeah you're right on the
right on the line uh that's that aside
can you just describe uh the commitment
that a warranty of firefighter has to
make uh to even get to the point where
he is a certified uh firefighter uh and
uh because that's a significant
commitment now can you just describe
what that takes to get there it's 120
hours to get your level one uh and then
uh continued there's a lot of
firefighters who continue on for vehicle
extrication and and if you want to go
for EMS there's another 120 uh 120 hours
for EMS and then 24 hours each uh two
years for uh continue education so to
get a five in you know back in the horse
and buggy days and I started was a whole
lot different but now we've made sure
that our firefighters are safe we've
added a larger curriculum uh we're also
trying to make sure that that it works
well for the volunteers trying to do a
little more online training with the
states they don't have to drive two
hours to get three hours of training two
hours back home to spend to go to work
the next day so there is a huge uh
commitment by the volunteers to to be a
certified firefighter if they just want
to go for level one then they go to
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Green for taking my question I'm
thinking about an earlier question about
for a person whose employment situation
doesn't isn't really appropriate for
being able to become in late or to
volunteer isn't that more incumbent upon
that person to make a decision whether
or not they should enter take this
so that so that if I were a a doctor and
I know that I often have surgeries at
nine o'clock in the morning this isn't
or or two o'clock in the afternoon in
the evening this isn't my this isn't
what for me
I think that's a personal choice
um you know everyone has their personal
choice you know we're not asking
everybody in town to be on a volunteer
fire department uh you know that's a
it's something that's in in you I mean I
wanted to be a firefighter since I was
three years old and I was you know most
of us who are on the fire department
want to be since we're we're little kids
but it's something that we I've always
enjoyed giving back to my community uh
that's what it's been for me everybody
has a different uh thing but uh you know
if you have a position an occupation a
profession where you can't leave in the
middle of night and you have to be there
that's your choice that's your decision
but I think what this bill is looking
toward is the the
people who are there serving their
Community if they come in an hour late
to their work because they're out on a
on an all-nighter uh that they aren't
penalized I mean they may not get paid
for it and that's fine I'm sure there's
a lot of hours I didn't get paid because
I showed up late but that was a choice
by me
follow up
thank you and and so again this is for
the this is for the people who can do
this that we're not to worry about the
people whose jobs aren't suitable for
this only those who desire to and can
many additional questions
Mr Green we spoke before the hearing and
I think it's important here for the
record
what information do you have
that you could give this committee
about
employers who have reprimanded or
discharged employees
or
you know doing their duty to go to a
fire or or such I I do personally do not
have any documentation I know that it's
been experienced over the years we had
one of our firefighters who worked for a
company with a family business and he
was told you got to decide you're going
to be a firefighter you're going to be
working in this business but you just
can't leave all the time or show up late
whenever you want that person had to
make that decision whether they were
going to be working in that business or
volunteering for the fire department
so those there's nothing documentation
on that that was just a conversation
that we had had that was experienced as
I told you I grew up in Amherst it was
all volunteer fire department a lot of
my business friends were firefighters
and such
but we have a situation where you just
mentioned you had an employer who
decided that they had to let someone go
because they could not have someone like
that that would come and go or not be
able to show up so where do we have this
this we have this fine line here between
needing volunteer firefighters to be
able to do the job that is needed and
telling employers they can't discipline
someone if they can't show up to work
that is the the the
difficulty that we have here so I would
How would
you how do we address this the best of
your knowledge how do we address this
while trying to do what we need to do to
help the citizens have firefighters but
dealing with employers
I think looking at other states seeing
if other states have this same structure
uh the firefighter in question in my my
analogy was not fired he had to make a
decision uh whether he was going to run
a lot of calls or you know back off uh
but I think it's uh it's important that
those in the fire service serving their
communities have as much protections as
possible it's not telling the business
what to do or how to do but if
firefighter shows up an hour too late
for work because they're giving back to
the community I think they should be
afforded some protections
the employer doesn't have to pay them
you have to run an hourly scale I
wouldn't expect an employer to pay them
representative attitude thank you Mr
chairman thank you
um
if I told you that uh many state
legislators who are also volunteer have
experienced similar uh Do or Die
situations where they've had to make a
choice between uh being here and keeping
their job would that surprise you
I'm sorry I've run that past me again if
I told you that many volunteer state
legislators have experienced the same
anecdotal situations that many of the
volunteer firefighters have would that
surprise you
no it wouldn't follow up
would you agree with me that volunteer
firefighters are probably more important
to continue to have do their volunteer
I think that's a trap
I agree Amendment I'll refer to not
answer that question if I'm allowed I
think my point was established
thank you representative attitude any
being done thank you Mr Green thank you
for letting me uh take the time and uh
and visit with you thank you
I'm told by uh representative soucy that
I have the wrong bill that Mr McAllister
would like to um
uh he wants to testify this afternoon it
is 10 25. I have no additional pink
cards
seeing none we're going to have Mike
Cahill
uh give us a lesson in and how to use
okay
actually I've got another idea could I
uh meet with the Democrats in the office
for just a couple minutes yes the
hearing on uh House Bill 182 FN is
closed
trying to deprive us of percussion
so
if you got the phone yeah oh I got it I
got it we need a law that prevents
firing of any state representatives or
anything
saying
it's abusing them
and
committee if you could uh take your
seats and get ready
hey Lennon your way out can I guess get
does anyone have any pink cards in it on
foreign
we are opening the hearing on House Bill
190 and uh okay recognize
Mr chairman representative Glenn
turcotte
thank you Mr chairman
good to be back in what was formerly the
best Committee in the house that now is
the house Municipal and County
government committee but it's good to be
see you all again uh representative Len
turcott from Stratford County District 4
which is uh now the towns of Barrington
and Stratford I'm currently in my fourth
term here and as uh chairman infantine
said I mean now uh chairman over on the
municipal and County government I did
serve three terms here in labor as well
as on finance redistricting
and a few other things I'm here to
introduce house bill 190. on behalf of
myself and some other members of
some chairs and vice chairs as well as
the bill this year HB 190 is almost a
carbon copy of last year's HB
1337. last year this bill passed in the
House of Representatives not once but
twice it passed on the house floor with
only by a vote of 179 and 153 with all
but three Republicans voting for it with
one Democrat who actually voted in favor
with us it was later brought forward as
a floor Amendment during a committee a
conference we attached it to a
a Senate bill and
it all died
so
when the bill last year went over to the
Senate they did what the Senate does
quite often and that is they don't like
us sending them too many bills so they
mix a lot of them and this was one that
they mixed
um
what this bill does it's a common sense
approach and a rational tool which does
several things one it incentivizes the
work ethic it will strengthen the
state's trust fund it will reduce the
unemployment insurance taxes that
businesses pay allowing the businesses
to use that savings for a number of
things better pay maybe maybe better
benefits or even expanding their
businesses
um currently this has this approach has
been taken in I think we're up to 10 or
11 states now with a universally
positive results some states better than
others uh what I will give you at the
end of this hearing is
um a white paper by the foundation for
government accountability that talks
so the mechanics of the bill how it
works
basically it initially reduces the
maximum number of weeks from 26 down to
24. currently we're at a half year
and it reduces at that 24 weeks it pegs
it to the unemployment rate in the state
this is the whole idea of the bill when
you in index the unemployment rate to
how long unemployed many weeks of
unemployment the individual can get so
at 24 weeks you would get that anytime
the unemployment rate is eight percent
or greater now that number reduces by a
half percent
reduces by one week for one for each one
half a percent the unemployment rate
goes down to a low of three percent
where the benefit would be at 14 weeks
currently as you know in the state of
New Hampshire we're below that three
percent so
today that number would be eligible for
the individual would be eligible for 14
uh some of the other points in the bills
that I
worked with the Deputy Commissioner
lavers last year on as we went through
this bill a couple of the issues that
came up or what happens
when you have a pandemic like we did
with the coronavirus or the 2008
economic crisis and in both situations
there the federal government's stepped
in but you'll also note in the bill
there's an R it mentions RSA for uh
colon 4 45 and what that is is the state
of emergency exception so in a state of
emergency if the governor declared he
could basically alter the the length of
time
also the uh the date at which the the
numbers taken the unemployment rate is
the fourth quarter uh again that was
based on
um
discussions with represent uh with
Deputy Commissioner labors
so
the longer individuals are unemployed
the more likely they are to fall into
long-term dependency or the frequency of
dependency and the harder it is to find
work at that point the studies of
numerous Studies have shown that
receiving these benefits for an extended
amount of time can reduce unemployment
unemployed workers job search efforts
and uh
I think the recent covid
pandemic of over the last couple years
has been an ex
perfect example of what can happen
businesses can't find workers because
people have gotten too too familiar with
being out on the sidelines I recall
specifically spring of 2021 last two
years ago
that uh
during the pandemic Governor sununu
initially wanted to continue the there
was a 300 extra amount that the
government was providing to the
unemployed and he was going to extend
that and quickly our businesses in New
Hampshire persuaded him to reverse that
position uh just because they needed to
get people back to work when you give
people money constantly and
um
over a long period of time the the
you get that kind of a result
what we've seen in the states
that allow benefits for 26 weeks like
New Hampshire currently do
individuals are staying out for an
average of 14 weeks that's uh current
according to the testimony that was
put into the back of the bill by the
in the states that have reformed these
systems the average is 8.6 weeks
so although New Hampshire's
is relatively good it's still almost
twice as much as many of these states
who have you know implemented this type
of a indexing system
now I've said before that these wages
unemployment wages are meant to be a
temporary replacement of a part of a
person's income they're not supposed to
becoming a permanent entitlement and I'm
going to give you a great example this
is an email I received last year
uh from an individual not a constituent
but from an individual up north
and it's an example of what happens when
you give the man a fish over and over
and over rather than teaching them how
how to fish
and this was after the it had the senate
had uh or it was about the time we were
dealing with this in the Senate
and it was from an individual and I'll
just read it
it says from what I understand you want
to cut the weeks of unemployment
by 10 weeks
I am in construction I am laid off
mid-november till mid-april that means
for me three months of no income for me
or my family I have a mortgage to pay
oil and many bills to pay so if this
bill passes you can pay my bills for
those 10 weeks you want to get rid of
where are your brains
sincerely and his name
now what I later found out that this is
this is not atypical I had further
conversations with with this individual
via email and this individual has been
doing this for decades
they work six six and a half months
and then they have the expectation that
they're going to sit at home and collect
the unemployment for the remainder and
it's not unique as I talked with the
Deputy Commissioner about this he also
mentioned that this is not an infrequent
situation
with today's
unemployment rate
and the inability of businesses to find
workers
there's nobody here that's going to tell
me that individual can't find another
job for
for five or six months that will where
he can he or she can make uh
substantially
a lot more money for those five or six
months
uh than on unemployment probably close
to double
I mean these days you can't find a job
that
pays less than twenty dollars an hour to
start
and you can be sure those businesses who
can't find
employees would be more than happy
to have that individual for five months
so in closing I'll just say that the
unemployment indexing is rationals
responsible it's Common Sense uh it
gives a longer term of payments when the
unemployment rate is high and in shorter
terms when unemployment is low I want to
remind you right now it's up to a half
year even though
the average is about 14. yes
you've seen in the testimony attached to
the bill that we have a very good system
it is a good system but do we simply sit
back and say We'll accept good when we
can potentially make that system uh
better
I think
um again I'm going to go back to the
keep calling it testimony in the back of
the bill because I've never seen such a
long
um
methodology explanation
we have a shortage of workers today I
mean there's no doubt about it we need
to get more people working we don't want
to extend the welfare unemployment rule
this will ultimately save the businesses
unemployment insurance taxes
we've learned over the last couple years
a second segment of our population will
remain idle when the monthly total
payments are high at one point if you
remember they reached almost 3 600 a
month here in New Hampshire
New Hampshire system is good
but we can make it better I sense
there's a a fear of change
that maybe the administration of the
current program sees
I don't see that I see an improvement
will it be Monumental in New Hampshire's
case probably not some of the other
states as we talked about it was very
monumental
and once again I'll say 26 weeks that's
our maximum that is an entire half of
the year
so with that I'd be happy to take any
questions I do have committee to get
back to but I would be more than happy
to take any questions and then I will
pass out the white paper
thank you representative turcott are
there any questions
I I have won last year uh we brought
this up you mentioned a significant
change in what happened in Florida when
this happened and then in the beginning
of your testimony you talked about
this implementing this would save money
to the the New Hampshire trust fund and
although it's not written in this
as you say lengthy
um Financial note you have any
guess as to the savings that might occur
no
but analytically
there will be a savings what that what
the amount will be I I couldn't tell you
um in the this that I'll pass out from
Florida it was significant they turned
out a massive bill multi-billion dollar
deficit into a a positive uh for the
unemployment insurance fund and then
they were able to bring that down
significantly
um
I'm pretty sure deputy
commissioner ladders might have addicts
that number for you
representative McKenzie uh represent
turkai good to see you again
um
just a question you're going to pass a
white paper out to us I guess is what
you said are you the author of that
white paper
I am not the foundation for a government
all right see you more thank you very
assistant commissioner
Richard Lewis New Hampshire Employment
Securities
the papers are lacking
thank you
Mr assistant commissioner welcome
good morning uh thank you for
opportunity to
talk with the committee uh this morning
I'll let those
handouts make their way around
just for the record uh Richard laver's
Deputy Commissioner New Hampshire
Department of Employment Security
I'm going to walk through
the slides that I've handed out but
certainly as questions arise please
interrupt me because I'm going to try to
move through those fairly quickly in
respect of your time but again as
questions come up please stop me and
I'll do my best to answer those so I
believe in the materials that you have
there I think we address the issues that
representative turcott has brought up
with his motivation for filing this bill
I believe he talked about improving work
ethic talked about strengthening the
trust fund employee improving employer
taxes making for a faster return to the
labor force
talked about Florida as the state used
as the example of why to do this and
then talked about trust fund solvency I
think all of those issues are addressed
but as you have additional questions
about any of those please fire away
um so the the department opposes this
bill we opposed the bill last go around
in the Senate
we have not had an opportunity to review
this bill with the unemployment
compensation advisory Council the
council has their regular quarterly
meeting coming up this Monday
chairman infantine will be there for
that
the
majority of that meeting will be focused
on legislation we'll be presenting this
bill to the council they may take a
position and if they do we will
certainly assist the Council and getting
that position conveyed to the committee
but the department opposes the bill
um starting starting with the slides to
give you a lay of the land on on how New
Hampshire Compares with the rest of the
country in terms of how many weeks of
unemployment benefits are currently
available
um you can see that New Hampshire is in
the mainstream right now in terms of
their unemployment program and what is
available for individuals we have 42
States right now that have at least 26
weeks available on this first chart that
you see all of the green states have 26
weeks Massachusetts has
28 or 30 I'm sorry and then Montana has
28 weeks currently available so we do
have and these are states and
territories so we do have 10 states that
have less than 26 weeks available
when we look at the states with at least
26 weeks available
10 of them have a uniform duration
meaning that someone comes in qualifies
for for unemployment benefits because we
are an eligibility based program you
have to have a qualifying separation be
unemployed through no fault of your own
be able able to work available to work
actively conducting a work search each
and every week so we are an
eligibility-based program not an
entitlement program like
um was
discussed in the sponsor's testimony so
10 States including New Hampshire have a
uniform 26 weeks available when an
individual comes in and files we'll go
over how many weeks people are currently
using how many people use all those
weeks but right now you come in you
qualify you have 26 up to 26 weeks
available to you
32 of those 42 states that have
up to 26 weeks they have a variable
duration so you can get up to 26 but
they look at your base period earnings
so how much you earned in your base
period and over how many quarters you
earned wages in your base period the
more you earned over more quarters in
your base period the more weeks you are
eligible for the less you earned over a
shorter duration during your base period
the fewer amount of weeks that you are
eligible for but up to 26 weeks so if
you had earnings over the course of your
whole four quarter base period you're
going to be collecting for 26 weeks
of the 10 states that have less than 26
weeks so Florida being one of them
Florida is currently 12 weeks available
like North Carolina also has 12 weeks
available
six of those 10 have variable duration
that is based on their base period wages
like I just talked about with the the
other states but they also look at
unemployment rate like representative
turcott is proposing here so they don't
just look at unemployment rate they look
at what your base period earnings were
as well and both of those issues go into
the calculation to determine how many
weeks you will receive and then four of
those 10 states that have less than 26
weeks they they base that determination
entirely upon base period wages they
don't look at unemployment rate
so again Florida North Carolina they
have 12 weeks available Alabama Georgia
have 14 weeks available like being
proposed here
um when we we moved to the next chart
here you can see and this should be
familiar to to the members of the
committee because we briefly talked
about it during the orientation but the
the lay of the land right now in New
Hampshire in terms of utilization of the
unemployment program you can see in this
chart for new claims we are 30 below
where we were pre-pandemic uh country as
a whole is 10 below where they were so
New Hampshire is an outlier in terms of
the low volume of claims currently being
filed the next slide when you look at
those weekly claims so someone needs to
file an initial claim and a weekly claim
and then a weekly claim each week that
they remain unemployed and are seeking
unemployment benefits those weekly
claims are 36 percent below where we
were pre-pandemic and we thought things
were pretty good in 2019 uh before the
pandemic hit unemployment rate at 2.7
percent employers struggling to find
worker others nearing full employment
but we are 36 percent below where we
were in 2019 in terms of weekly filings
when you look at Massachusetts and New
Hampshire
they are below where they were but not
anywhere close to what New Hampshire is
experiencing so New Hampshire is an
outlier in that regard
when we move to the the next page and
the uh the fourth slide
it looks at duration very very important
Point uh here uh because it was it was
stressed upon with representative
turcotte and the the rationale for
proposing this is that duration is a
problem in states that have a high
number of weeks available to them
well the current data on that actually
suggests quite the opposite so New
Hampshire right now despite having 26
weeks of benefits available on average
individuals utilize 10 weeks
so their unemployment claim utilizes
less than half of the weeks they have
available to them and this simple reason
for that is because it's not necessarily
a matter of how many weeks you have
available to you that really determines
how long your main on the unemployment
program it's what are the economic
conditions in your state
that how many jobs are available to you
how many good quality jobs are available
to you and then also how much is being
paid to you while you're receiving
unemployment how much of your wages from
your prior employment are being replaced
so when you look at each and every state
and what their current average duration
is New Hampshire does quite well fifth
lowest average duration in the country
at 10 weeks
shorter duration than Florida
shorter duration than North Carolina
so
might be scratching your head on that
one so states that have 12 weeks maximum
available to them right now
people filing in those States file for
more weeks than in New Hampshire
despite New Hampshire having 26 weeks
available and again it's because the
economic conditions in the state in
which you are looking for employment
matter much more than the amount of the
number of weeks that you have available
and so you can see in on that chart the
yellow bars are the states that have
shorter or a lower number of weeks
available and you can see where they
shake out in terms of their average
duration
when you move to the the next slide
which looks at a very similar topic but
looks at exhaustion rates so exhaustion
is looking at how many people that file
for benefits how many of them use all of
the benefits they have available to them
so in New Hampshire that would be all 26
weeks
New Hampshire is the lowest exhaustion
rate in the whole country
okay
8.6 percent of people filing for
unemployment benefits in New Hampshire
utilize all 26 weeks now on average
they're using 10
but less than one out of every 10 people
that file for unemployment benefits in
New Hampshire currently utilize all 26
weeks
now when we look at Florida
in North Carolina
they have the highest exhaustion rates
in the country
fewer weeks granted each of those states
have 12 weeks available to them
but they have higher exhaustion rates so
right now in Florida nearly 70 percent
7-0
of their people filing for unemployment
benefits utilize all 12 weeks
New Hampshire that's 8.6 percent Florida
worst in the country for exhaustion New
Hampshire best in the country for
exhaustion
when we go to the the next slide which
compares
Florida and New Hampshire over the last
five years looking at exhaustion rates
um you can see there's really not much
of a comparison
so we look back at the the
pandemic recession Florida was at a
hundred percent exhaustion New Hampshire
30 percent
we look now we're near that 70
exhaustion 67.4 percent precisely for
Florida and 8.6 percent for New
Hampshire
so the suggestion that individuals in
the unemployment program are going to
use all of the weeks they have available
to them
is not true based on experience and
administering that program but it's not
true based on the actual data and it's
not a fluke it's not just because I
picked I cherry-picked a great quarter
to use you've got five years of data
right here comparing Florida and New
when we move to the the next slide and
we look at
a comparison of
um
and I've got to make a point here having
an economist that works for you with
Brian gottlub is a wonderful thing to
have I know the song said Lawyers Guns
and Money but having an economist is
great
um
when you when you look at uh mapping out
and overlaying
the proposed weeks in the the formula
for calculating those weeks in House
Bill 190 and you put that over history
going back to 2000. so that covers three
recessionary periods a modest one a
severe one and then an explosive one
with the pandemic recession
and you look at our actual average
duration
you can see that
what would have happened with if House
Bill 190 had been in place in New
Hampshire
that during each recessionary period and
coming out of those recessionary periods
there would not have been enough weeks
to satisfy the demand at the time for
people that were filing for unemployment
so the red line here is the proposal the
proposed number of weeks that would be
available based on the the calculation
using the fourth quarter's unemployment
rate
and the blue line shows you what the
actual average duration was the gray
bars are the recessions
so 2001 you can see actual duration much
higher than that which would have been
allowed by House Bill 190 similar to the
the 2008 recession and then very much
true during the pandemic recession
and so
the the good thing of one of many good
things about the unemployment program in
New Hampshire
is that it is sized to meet the demand
so right now we're doing a good job of
getting people back to work the
department would like to take some
credit for that but I think private
employers probably deserve more credit
for that because they have jobs
available so the economic conditions are
good people don't need
right now they only need 10 weeks on
average of the 26 weeks available
but that's not what where you know
policy isn't just looking at what we're
currently experiencing we need to look
at what is going to happen again at some
point we experience a recession every
seven years so it's going to happen
again and when we have had recessionary
periods looking at the three most recent
people need more weeks because of the
economic conditions at the time
House Bill 190 would not have provided
sufficient numbers of weeks during those
periods and ironically it would have
provided more weeks when we were in
recovery recovery periods when people
didn't need them because it relies Upon
A lagging indicator with the
unemployment rate I know we published
the unemployment rate so why am I
bashing the unemployment rate well you
notice we don't really use it for much
we put it out there and say hey this is
where we were last month
but it's not something we use to
determine where we are right now and
where we're going we actually use a
whole assortment of of real-time high
frequency indicators not a lagging
indicator like the unemployment rate but
you can see how House Bill 190 would
have performed in those three
and addressing the point made about uh
uh work ethic and uh
you know reducing the number of weeks to
strengthen work ethic reducing the
number of weeks to to strengthen and
um increase the labor force
um so we know that New Hampshire on
average 10 weeks right so I think work
ethic is pretty good in New Hampshire we
historically have a higher labor force
participation rate than the rest of the
country and we have a lower average
duration of unemployment benefits than
the rest of the country both good
indicators for what our work ethic here
but when you look at this next chart
with the red yellow and blue bars this
looks at New Hampshire Florida and North
Carolina and what it does is it looks at
individuals that filed a new
unemployment claim how many of them
had actual wages in the next quarter
okay
so New Hampshire
this data which is uh five years ending
in 2018
Florida stopped submitting data I don't
know why but so this is up to 2018 uh 72
percent of individuals filing a new
claim showed wages in the next quarter
meaning they were getting right back to
work uh Florida down about 57 percent
North Carolina at about 65 percent if we
were to walk this forward to the most
current available data New Hampshire has
about 78 of individuals that file a new
claim show wages in the next quarter I
don't know Florida North Carolina
because that data is not currently
available
um looking at the the next slide and the
issue about
um healthy trust fund and healthy
unemployment program
um what this slide does is it looks at
each State's Reliance on federal
assistance during the pandemic for
unemployment purposes
and
why this is important and why we looked
at this was
we felt New Hampshire had done a really
good job of paying people from the
correct program and which results in
less audit findings and less problems
with the US Department of Labor down the
road
but we also had a right-sized
unemployment program so because we had
26 weeks available we had a solvent
trust fund at the start of the pandemic
governor sununa was able to actually
create and expanded unemployment program
providing benefits to Gig workers and
self-employed and people that didn't
have enough wages he was able to do that
about two weeks ahead of the federal
government passing the cares act again
because he had a solvent trust fund he
had 26 weeks available States that had
fewer weeks didn't have that option to
them they couldn't react as quickly as
New Hampshire could and what you see
here in this chart is that states that
have fewer weeks available in their
unemployment program they rely upon the
federal government to bail them out much
more quickly and to a much higher degree
this looks at how many dollars in
pandemic unemployment benefits were paid
per covered worker in each state you can
see New Hampshire did very well we're
over on the left hand side of this
column Florida was about out twice as
much pandemic unemployment assistance
that that state needed in order to
address the workers needs during the
pandemic then New Hampshire needed again
because of the weeks The Limited number
of weeks they had available and as we'll
get into also because of the solvency or
um when we when we talk I know there had
been some questions about and I'd raised
the point about the amount that someone
gets paid on unemployment has an impact
on how quickly they're going to be
returning to work New Hampshire has
about a 30 percent wage replacement rate
on average right now our average weekly
benefit amount and this slide looks at
each state's average weekly benefit
amount currently New Hampshire is at
about 320 dollars a week 17th lowest in
the Country Florida they're at 253
dollars a week average weekly benefit
amount
um write down with Mississippi Louisiana
and Alabama in terms of how much they
and again
um
with New Hampshire that wage replacement
rate is about 30 percent
um so and that's a comparison of what
someone would receive on unemployment
compared to what they were earning in
private sector employment
um when you look at this next slide you
can see the New Hampshire and Florida
actually are are pretty close despite
Florida having a much lower average
weekly benefit amount they're both at
about 30 percent
um country as a whole is about 38
percent wage replacement
New Hampshire and Florida are close just
because Florida is a low-wage state
compared to New Hampshire so that's why
despite New Hampshire having a higher
weekly benefit amount we also have
higher private sector average earnings
so that's why we're close even though we
have a higher average weekly benefit
amount
when we when we Turn the Page we get
into some of the tax issues and
arguments that have been brought forward
that the reducing the number of weeks is
healthier for Employers in the state
from a from an unemployment insurance
tax perspective what you can see here
is and we share this in our orientation
session but New Hampshire has seen
explosive growth in employers since the
pandemic we're up about 21 percent we
added about 9 000 registered Employers
in the state
um the tax experience of employers in
the state
we peaked at a unemployment insurance
tax rate that was about 40 percent below
where we peaked during the Great
Recession that tax rate has come down
significantly
um the quarter that you cannot see here
which would be Q4 of 2022 that data is
not available for this slide that rate
will be down around one percent and we
know that because employers started
receiving their their fund balance
reduction because of the growth in the
trust fund they started receiving that
in the fourth quarter so everyone got a
half Point reduction in their
unemployment rate starting with the
fourth quarter they're getting it in the
first quarter as well saving them about
28 million dollars so tax rates have
been falling
and then the last slide looking at
getting into the solvency discussion and
I want to spend some time
talking about this
and there's a whole bunch of numbers
that I don't have memorized so I need to
get to my
notes Here
uh
but when we look at trust fund solvency
it's an incredibly important topic okay
there's I think six people in the state
that really care about it chairman
infant times one I'm another one Brian
gottlub is one
um and I think Gary Abbott he actually
has a strange fascination with trust
fund solvency sitting behind me but it's
an incredibly important topic for
employers and the reason why it's
important is because if you have a
solvent trust fund then when you get
into an economic downturn then the
likelihood is that you will not need to
borrow from the federal government in
order to pay unemployment benefits
during that economic downturn
states that need to borrow then face
problems for their Employers in the form
of reductions in their federal
unemployment insurance tax credits so
when that happens employers start having
to pay more in taxes to support the
unemployment program or their Federal
share of unemployment insurance taxes so
borrowing is not a good thing it's good
to have that support from the federal
government if you are unable to meet the
obligations of your your unemployed
population but long term not good for
the Employers in your state
um what we have here is the solvency
scores of all the states
okay so every April the U.S Department
of Labor publishes a solvency report in
that report they
provide analysis and give a score to
every State's trust fund and what they
look at is they look at what your
current trust fund balance is as of
January of that year so the most recent
report we have is from April of 22 they
use January balances for that report
they then look at your three worst
benefit years in the last 20 years and
then they look at what your total wages
are in the state because they're really
all about assessing risk right it's an
insurance program Insurance product we
care very much about risk
they then give each state a score that
they call the average high cost multiple
the ahcm okay if you achieve a score of
1.0
ahcm you are considered minimally
solvent by U.S department of labor
meaning they think that you can probably
pay benefits out of your trust fund when
you encounter the next economic downturn
they don't know you know I used to joke
around saying solvency is like getting
ready for a race I don't know am I
getting ready for a 5k or a marathon I
don't know if I'm going to be in good
enough shape we don't know what the next
economic downturn is going to be but
this is what U.S Department of Labor
uses to try to measure that so when they
took that measurement prior to the
pandemic 2019 New Hampshire was solvent
we had an ahcm of 1.04 in Florida
Florida was also solvent okay Florida
was a slightly higher ahcm they're 1.07
so a little bit more solve than New
Hampshire at that time
we had about 311 million dollars in our
trust fund at that point in time Florida
had 3.8 billion okay of course the
state's 17 times the size of New
Hampshire the labor force is 15 times
the size of New Hampshire so having a
trust fund that's 12 times the size of
New Hampshire it's about right okay we
were both solvent though when you looked
at usdol
fast forward to 2023 and based on the
report that was filed or released in
April of of 22 because that's the most
recent one we have neither of the states
were solvent okay New Hampshire was at
about 0.55 remember we want a 1.0 ahcm
to be considered solvent Florida was at
about a point three four
but what we can do in anticipating the
next report that will come out in April
of this year because again that April 22
report looks at trust fund balances from
January of 22. we can look at what we've
had for trust fund growth in that time
period so New Hampshire's trust fund
went from 190 million when they released
that report finding that we were not
solvent we're now at 360 million
Okay so we've had about 84 percent
growth in our trust fund over the course
of that time period when you apply those
figures to our ahcm New Hampshire is
currently solvent good news so we have
an ahcm that is over 1.0 it's higher
than where we were prior to the pandemic
um you know we're about 50 million
um above where we were prior to the
pandemic so New Hampshire is solvent
Florida's not
so Florida's had about 40 percent growth
in their trust fund Revenue during that
time period remember they started prior
to the pandemic at 3.8 billion they're
now at about 2 billion but they're not
solvent they're not even close to
solvent when you apply that growth in
their trust fund to their prior report
that puts them under 0.5 so they're not
even halfway to being solvent that's a
problem
um but I I think when you when you look
at
um the statistics and the numbers that
we've talked about you can understand
why
um based upon the lack of solvency in
Florida and why they have only 12 weeks
available and they can't afford to pay
individuals for more weeks because they
don't do a very good job of getting
individuals back to work
they have high exhaustion rates so more
than two-thirds of their people use all
the weeks that are available to them New
Hampshire less you know less than one in
ten use all the weeks available to them
New Hampshire has shorter duration
despite more weeks available so we on
average people use 10 weeks Florida
North Carolina on average people use 11
weeks
um so without a solvent trust fund
and without real good effort on working
to make connections between hiring
employers and job Seekers then I can see
why you wouldn't offer more weeks
because in Florida it is true people use
all the weeks that are available to them
New Hampshire that is not the case the
department feels that our current
structure of our unemployment program 26
weeks available with with strict
requirements on weekly work search on
being able to work available to work and
heavily policing that as we do in our
responsible administration of the
program we feel that the program is
sized correctly now
any changes to that the concern would be
that we would be undersizing the program
we wouldn't have enough weeks available
to individuals when we encounter the
next economic downturn and we would be
making ourselves much more dependent
upon the federal government to bail us
out to bail out our unemployment program
in order to provide support to
individuals when they're unemployed
through no fault of their own because
the state can't afford to do it
now
I don't want to get to that point in
time and and I hope the the committee
agrees with the Department's position on
this I know I've thrown out a lot of
information to the members I do thank
you for giving me a little bit more time
and I hopefully can answer any questions
that folks might have
thank you thank you
um Mr Vice chairman
thank you
um my question is you heard the sponsor
gave us an example of a seasonal worker
who then uses unemployment for the
off-season could you help remind me what
the obligations are on say a
construction worker
in order to remain qualified for for
benefits during up to
half the year
so it it's a good point so right now in
New Hampshire
um seasonal employees are allowed to
file for unemployment's employment
benefits during their off season you're
also allowed to have part part-time
earnings while you're collecting
unemployment benefits so seasonal
workers so our our bus drivers our
school cafeteria workers our landscapers
our construction workers our civil
construction workers on Road and Bridge
projects during their off season those
individuals have a qualifying separation
from work they are allowed to file for
unemployment benefits on average they
get about 30 percent wage replacement so
30 percent of the wages they were
earning is what they're getting in
unemployment that's an incentive for
many people not to utilize the
unemployment Program in those situations
but they are eligible
what what happens with regard to the
obligation to search for work
is there was a change made in 2018
19 time period
um uh legislative change made so it's in
our statute so an individual that is on
a temporary layoff and they have a
definite date for return to work that is
less than 11 weeks away
they do not have to search for work
during the period that is less than 11
weeks so that can apply to bus drivers
it can apply to any of your seasonal
workers
if you're if your temporary layoff is
going to be longer than that period you
have to search Fork the entire period if
you don't have a definite date for
return to work you just your employer
thinks they're going to be bringing you
back you have to search for work that
entire time period and you do that on
your weekly claim filing when you're
doing that electronically so that's how
the current work search waiver is
implemented based upon the statutory
requirement
thank you could you further explain how
in doing that
for the new folks here how we reduce the
employers with a negative balance
so the as you can imagine this is a good
point getting into more about trust fund
solvency so employers that have seasonal
patterns to their Workforce have put a
much bigger burden on the unemployment
program right then say an employer that
doesn't have any seasonality in their
Workforce but occasionally we'll have a
need to lay somebody off so we have in
New Hampshire you you're either if
you're a for-profit employer you're
either positive rated or you're negative
rated okay so positive rated employers
are those employers that have paid more
into the unemployment program through
their quarterly tax payments than the
department has paid out and benefits to
their workers
negative rated employers many of whom
are seasonal employers are those that
have paid in less in taxes that we have
paid out in benefits what happens to
those negative rated employers is they
have a much higher tax rate
so if you are new to being negative
maybe that maybe there was just a a bump
in your um whatever your business area
was and you lost a few customers you had
to lay a few people off it caused you to
go negative if you're negative less than
four years then you move on to a middle
tax table your rates are a little bit
higher they're not as low as they were
when you were positive rated but they're
not as high as those chronically
negative rated employers that have more
of that that seasonal burden on the
employment unemployment program so those
those individual those employers that
are negative rated for more than four
years they're on the third table the
highest rates upwards of seven and a
half percent
and they also don't share in the
experience of those fund balance
reductions to the degree that are
positive rate rated employers do so they
pay at higher rates they have they're
paying in more taxes into the trust fund
because their experience is negative and
and your seasonal employers that have
regular seasonality like that fall into
that last group with the highest rates
thank you
representative McKenzie then so Paul by
Sullivan
all right
the uh the question I have is a phrase
that come up to you then I'm not real
familiar with this variable duration
and I'm particularly concerned about uh
the the impact on low-wage workers
if the unemployment benefit is based as
I understand it from representative
turcotte is based on the amount of wages
that you receive
um
in the and so low wage workers can you
explain how potentially that could
affect low-wage workers as opposed to
high wage workers who uh who may be
accumulated that very quicker so the so
just to clarify New Hampshire is a
uniform duration state right so when you
come in you have up to 26 weeks
available some states as we had had
reviewed some states have variable
duration looking at base period earnings
so how that how that works in New
Hampshire
so your base period is the first four of
the most recently completed five
calendar quarters
so we look at those four quarters and we
see what you earned in covered
employment W-2 employment and based upon
those total earnings is going to
determine what your weekly benefit
amount is so the weekly benefit amount
is set in statute is a statutory table
in 282a
you have minimal the minimal earnings
requirement during that base period is
twenty eight hundred dollars so during
those four quarters you have to have
earned fourteen hundred dollars in each
of two quarters in order to be
monetarily eligible so if you had twenty
eight hundred dollars in one quarter in
your base period and less than 14 and
all the other quarters you are not
monetarily eligible for unemployment
benefits so if you have that 1400 in
each of two quarters in your base period
your your weekly benefit amount would be
twenty seven dollars a week
um actually might even be less than that
I don't have the table memorized uh to
heart I know the the top end which is
427.
um that is what you would get if you
were at 41.5 during your base period so
if you earn at least forty one thousand
dollars 41 500 during your base period
during those four quarters you are going
to top out at the maximum weekly benefit
amount in New Hampshire 427 dollars a
week if you have a hundred thousand
dollars in your base period you get 427
a week if you have two hundred thousand
a week so we look at base period
earnings the more base period earnings
you have as long as you satisfy those
two quarters of at least 1400
um your weekly benefit amount increases
up to that 427 the less you have in
earnings during those four quarters than
the less your weekly benefit amount is
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman good to see you
Deputy Commissioner um
that 8.6 of people who use the full 26
weeks I'm it's a very low number
um Department should be proud New
Hampshire should be proud
um
but I'm interested in knowing who those
people are what what kind of life
experience have they gone through that
requires them unlike
um over 90 percent of everyone else who
goes on unemployment what causes them to
use the full 26 weeks
so it
and and thank you for the the comments
about the 8.6 percent we're proud of
that as well
um so one of the factors uh that does uh
come in when you're looking at the
number of weeks that someone files for
and and we had talked about this uh
during the uh the last session with with
this bill
um there are a large number of the
individuals that file for more weeks
they have part-time earnings
um so they're allowed to work part-time
um part-time hours part-time earnings
while they're collecting their
unemployment benefit but what it does is
those earnings reduce their unemployment
benefit
okay
and so when they're when they're working
part-time and those earnings are
reducing their unemployment benefit now
it's stretching out over how many weeks
you can get your maximum weeks available
to you okay so if you're working
part-time and say you normally would
have been getting
um 250 a week but with your part-time
earnings that's knocked down to a
hundred and fifty dollars a week now
you're getting less each week
your attachment to labor force is better
which is what we want to see but you
might need you might be filing for a
longer period of time but your weekly
benefit amount is going to be less so so
quite a few of those individuals in that
grouping that file for up to the 26
weeks and some file for for more than
that because they have the benefits
available to them because their
part-time earnings have been reducing
their maximum benefits available they
have they have those part-time earnings
and so those are more in your where
those where those jobs fall or more
likely be Hospitality retail with those
part-time workers and those are a lot of
the folks that use more weeks so
um that 8.6 very low number on average
were at 10 weeks
um but you do have those that are up up
in those higher
um weak groupings and I can share that
information
um with the committee I have uh 2018
uh 2019 and then
um the second half of 22.
um and the reason why I'll only provide
the second half of 22 is because it gets
out of the pandemic influence so but
what you can see based upon that data
2018-19 about 65 to 70 percent of people
were filing for less than 14 weeks
when you look at the 22 data about 76
percent of individuals are filing for
less than 14 weeks so that in that that
22 grouping I think it was 3 800
individuals that were in that sample
size so about 800 of them were filing
for more than more than 14 weeks so
you'll see that in the data that I make
available to chairman infantine
follow-up
still drilling down on those 8.6 percent
of the people other than the part-time
workers are there other folks who have
somehow fall on hard times that it's
making it
more difficult than usual for them to
actually be able to land a job of any
sort
um I think you're likely looking at
individuals who might require a longer
period of training
um perhaps they're going in a different
vocational Direction
and as long as that training is approved
training through the department they're
able to collect their unemployment
benefit while they're enrolled in
training perhaps that training is going
on uh longer putting them in that that
grouping of 8.6 of of exhaustees and
certainly above the 10 weeks average
duration in terms of other uh
characteristics of that group I don't
know it off the top of my head but we
can we can certainly look at that but
any other demographic characteristics at
least to the extent we have that
information
that can be provided as well thank you
just a moment I want to follow up on
something then I'll but I know people
have their hands off
following on representative Sullivan's
question about the 8.6 and the part-time
employees we now allow employees to
receive unemployment benefits When
possibly their employer because of a
seasonal situation doesn't want to lay
them off but only has fewer hours
so they can make unemployment of the
difference
it's important to me to understand what
percent is about 8.6 percent is that
so
because that's that's not someone that's
not
occasionally capable of going back to
work or someone that's milking it if you
will and not going back to work so I
don't know if you can and your numbers
break down break that down but that
would be important to me to understand
yeah we can show uh the number the
number of individuals in that 8.6
percent that actually show partial
earnings
um during their time filing your
representative McKenzie
thank you um this is always the case
with unemployment it's a rapid hole you
go down and it's very difficult to
unpack some of this stuff but let me uh
let me ask you uh this question is it
relates to construction workers as
opposed to in comparison to ordinary
workers
so when the unemployment system you have
to be you have to be available for work
so you deny people who come in and say
we can't we're not available for work
uh and yet there is an exception in the
in the in the law that allows people in
the construction industry who are going
to come back at some point there's a
fixed period they they're not required
to look for work is that correct
correct they're not if if they fit
within that uh having a definite date
for return to work in less than 11 weeks
they do not have to conduct a weekly
work search but they do need to be able
for work and they need to be available
for work
so if you were to break your leg during
that time period and you are not able to
work you're not available to work you
are not eligible for unemployment
benefits during that time that you're
representative Schultz well
because we
I'm not gonna say it I was just gonna I
I just don't think they need to earn
more we've already freaked them out with
all this all this stuff so far all the
newbies I don't want to give them too
much
unfortunately as uh commissioner
suswister said I've become kind of a
nerd about all this stuff so I'm sorry
there any other questions for the
yes
uh and I think I asked you asked you
this uh before but
you know I'm concerned about the impact
um
of those people who are ineligible as a
result of the uh
for instance during covet day care
center is closed their whole support
system went out from under them and many
people had to leave their Workforce
and so the question I have did that
impact women
uh female workers women workers as
opposed to male workers and what is the
what is the percentage of that I don't
expect you to answer that right now uh
but I'd be interested in that because
as we know the whole bottom fell out for
so many people and those people are not
eligible in many cases for unemployment
so the during the pandemic individuals
that were that had been working or had
been engaged in self-employment that
were no longer able to because of the
pandemic they were eligible and they
were filing including self-employed so
if if
fast forward to today you need to have a
qualifying separation meaning unemployed
through no fault of your own you need to
have monetary eligibility meaning at
least twenty eight hundred dollars in
your base period when covered employment
and then you would be eligible for
benefits experience during the pandemic
I can quickly answer that question so I
don't have more homework
during the height of the pandemic we're
from a gender breakdown we're looking
about 60 female okay 60 of the people
filing for unemployment benefits
um and the the pandemic related program
were women
compare that to our most recent
recessionary period back in the Great
Recession that was flipped so during the
Great Recession it was 60 men the reason
for both of those is because of the
sectors that were impacted
pandemic service sectors were much
higher impacted those sectors have a
higher percentage of female workers so
your house your hospitality Health Care
retail
they have more female employees than
they do men
they were more impacted during the
pandemic hence more of the filers for
unemployment being women Great Recession
big impacts were in construction
Financial Services manufacturing to a
certain degree those Industries tend to
be dominated by men so that's why there
were more men filing during the Great
Recession as compared to more women
filing during the pandemic recession
fast forward to where we are currently
and looking at the groups that have been
slow to return to the labor force I
believe we had looked at that broken
down by age cohort during the
orientation
and we've had a a drop in labor force
participation amongst our 25 to 34 year
olds
right
um older workers have come back
um even exceeding their pre-pandemic
participation younger workers have not
still off by five six percent which is
why our labor force is still not yet
where it was prior to the pandemic when
you look at that 25 to 34 year old
grouping that is more likely to have
young kids
more of those individuals more women in
that group have not come back to the
labor force as compared to men
so the one can take that next step and
say that the child care or lack thereof
for that population who are most likely
to and be in need of child care
those UH responsibilities tend to fall
more on female workers than they do male
workers not in my household
but generally they do
and you see a slower return to the labor
force amongst women 25 to 34 year old as
compared to their male counterparts in
all right
if you have any questions if you were
really kind of confused you can all feel
free to contact
assistant commissioner on your own
I have four cards I'd like to get this
hearing in 30 minutes but I'm not going
to stop anyone from uh from speaking
Gary Abbott associated general
contractors
since he was spoken of earlier in 2008
Gary Abbott
almost single-handedly saved the New
Hampshire
unemployment trust fund with coming up
with a new mechanism what we use now
it was a tough pill to swallow at the
time increasing from 12 to 14 000 of
benefits and putting a one-week delay in
but that was pretty much your idea Gary
and that was a really difficult time
uh thank you very much Jim and infantine
for that uh yeah it was back in that uh
recession in which the governor got a
number of business organizations
including us how we're going to solve
the problem and it included a tax rate
for businesses and we phased it in but I
appreciate that I'm going to try to keep
my testimony short I know you're running
on time in the commissioner has done
such an excellent job before me so part
of this comes that we did testify last
year when a similar bill was in place we
were in opposition let me introduce
myself from Gary Abbott the Executive
Vice President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire I represent
large commercial contractors both
building and Highway
uh this bill last year I brought a
highway contractor with me because this
is really I did a quick survey last year
based on the sponsor asking me to do so
of how many weeks for seasonal and I
represent uh I have construction firms
that do less than you know uh they have
different ranges so I didn't I did a
quick survey and I came down to what I
got responses back is uh 16 to 20 weeks
so I got different companies responding
that would be adequate and you can
imagine Paving was at the entire number
of 20 because Paving is temperature
related and they can be shut down
earlier than other construction firms
and unlike Florida we have Winters here
and they can't work
so they were concerned that you know no
fault of their own of an individual that
works for them gets laid off qualifies
because keep in mind our time period
goes for those layoffs typically more
than 14 weeks so they have to look for
work they have to do all of that and
there is no guarantee you do have
construction firms that might not be
able to go back into work the next year
this may be not a seasonal layoff it may
be permanent so that's why it's
structured the way it is that a person's
eligible there's an intent to come back
to work but as you know some employees
that go on unemployment might find a job
elsewhere and may never come back to
construction so it's a reality that we
live with
so we just want to protect we want as
much of our Workforce to come back as we
possibly can now keep in mind
the commissioner talked about the amount
the amount is not anywhere near the
wages that they could earn but there is
a difficulty if you're in the paving
industry and you have expert in that
and you tell an employer that you're
trying to go to work for that you're
probably most likely will go back to
work in the paving industry in the
spring it makes it much more difficult
if you're honest with those other
employers that you're going to go to a
different job and that may hurt you
trying to get the job but trying to be
honest with that so one of the things we
came down with and last year we opposed
it but I think we got a lot of
information and I know the commissioner
talked about facts and figures one thing
we took away from last year
and you can see that we kind of looked
and counted weeks and we said
we really if you were going to start
this phase-in of what the bill and we're
not opposed to the concept of the bill
because I think there's a Gap a curve
beyond the average and we got this from
the Deputy Commissioner last year the
bulk of the unemployment goes away in 17
weeks so I looked at my numbers of 16 to
20 talked to the contractors and said if
that curve
17 weeks a much higher than a majority
come off because you probably have the
seasonal that's part of those numbers of
the past before covet and one of the
things with covid we did as construction
industry continue to work through copen
so even when covet was hit in the
construction season we kept our people
employed but what we basically said if
there was going to be a phase in to look
at those people that are going all the
way to the end because that's really I
think what the bill is trying to do we
understand that as a policy but we think
the 14 weeks should start with a 17-week
and if that's the more than the majority
you know this kind of bell curve that
was the big number last year that we
heard from the the unemployment security
that's why we recommended 17 weeks
because if you go beyond that then you
have that policy but we would leave that
up to the committee but we think 14
weeks is too short
and with that I would end my testimony I
think you've heard an awful lot of facts
and figures and I'm just here to support
uh if you were to go forward with that
policy change
try to make it to the 17 weeks
thank you representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Abbott for taking my question I I tended
to uh I listened to what the Deputy
Commissioner labor said and I I think
that's what we have is working fine I I
don't really see
they need a benefit to change it but as
knowing that your Devotion to the trust
fund
uh I wanted to ask you about you know
as you know when when you have seasonal
labor is if you pay them their their two
weeks vacation
that Shields the trust fund from two
weeks of benefits and I'd imagine in the
construction field that you might be at
the Forty one thousand five hundred
which would be forty four twenty seven a
week
is that would that be would that be a
way of shielding of protecting the trust
fund while ensuring that you're you know
employees had a full week's pay for each
of those vacations I I guess what I
don't want to mix
companies develop their own policies
regarding vacation sick pay whether they
handle health care through a layoff
there's a lot of policy decisions I
think on this bill we're at least for me
I'm focused on
if they're eligible how does it work and
how many weeks based on what we have
today I can't tell you every company how
that you know if they're paid I agree
with the Department in the sense that
those are how the regulations go and we
conform to that no difference than years
ago when they changed we used to not
have to look for work many many years
ago but the legislature and the
department changed that so we look for
work just like anybody else which I
think is fair
oh yeah there's two hours I do
understand that your workers are
probably looking for work because
there's quite a gap between you know 30
you know you're missing 370 dollars and
I'd be looking for that someplace so I
understand your people are probably
working where they can
yeah and and I just want to play not
everyone that works for a seasonal
worker a seasonal company
goes on unemployment
they may do some other work and not do
that because they don't want to have to
look for work and all those other things
so I don't think it's a an absolute but
somebody who absolutely needs the money
and actually is looking for work then
they'll go into the system
thank you
so any other questions thank you Mr
Abbott thank you
I'm sorry Mr McKenzie go ahead
and see your hand
um
so the model that you're describing
um where people go on uh seasonal
workers
that's a very different model than what
the union Workforce uh has
in that if you acknowledge this that
there is a difference between a hiring
Hall and what and what you do and the
because they are always looking for work
in the labor in the union side of it you
represent I think some Union contractors
as well so is that so it it there's a
difference between those two
those two environment those two models I
think what you're saying is is not
necessarily
um because I think even if you're a
union Highway that has seasonal work you
would end up in that same situation even
though you were Union because I do
represent some Union firms so I don't
think it would be different a lot of the
model for construction though is looking
at building construction and you may
work on a project that ends you don't
know when it's going to start again
could be within but I don't think
there's guarantees for the Department to
say you don't have to look for work so I
I don't think the model you know I have
to look at I do represent this bigger
umbrella it's not just this one many uh
companies will won't use you know the
whole period of time because there'll be
another project but it varies whether
you're Union or open shop but it still
is you could be left without a job for a
thank you Mr Robert thank you
and next I like to call Roy swaker
representing himself thank you welcome
to the labor committee
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm back here again after last
year and essentially I have a very
similar thing to say namely that uh
we need to think of these as people and
not as statistics I mean you could
easily you know cut the thing by
eliminating benefits to two weeks and
you of course then you'd also get 100
exhaustion because no one's going to
find a new job in two weeks but anyway
I what I'd like you to think about is
why are these people still not working
in 26 weeks I mean some people have been
thinking about that I think that we had
the construction model talked about I
think that what you need to do is can
you bifurcate that that people that work
in certain sectors the employer just pay
enough to keep their that part of the
trust fund solvent so you're not worried
about that running out and then you know
leave the people that are not in
seasonal work to kind of have their own
part of the trust fund if these
companies are really paying enough money
for their seasonal workers then fine
what do we care if they're uh for 20
weeks if that's the way that that
industry wants to operate
and so and that's the first thing I want
to say the second thing it has to do
with uh last year my complaint was that
the New Hampshire Works was only open
half of the day and they've cured that
they're back to a full day and they've
also come up with this new uh job portal
which I sent you some slides about I
don't know how many people bothered to
look at them yet but this job portal to
me looks like it's designed to help
people that don't want to go back to
work and it makes it worse for the
people that actually want a job
because if you look at it
you know you can select types of work
you can select areas and so forth but
then what you get is a list of jobs in
that area
and apparently this is not particularly
attractive to employers because I notice
in concrete which is what I looked at
there was no big box stores in the list
is that really true that no big box
stores in Concord are looking for help
or is it just this job portal is not
useful to them so they don't bother
listing their jobs on it but the more
interesting thing that about this job
portal is there's both a link on the
left with the job title and a link on
the right inquire and they both bring up
the same page on that page you have 200
characters to explain why you want this
job
and you know it's 200 characters enough
and but what you don't get in this
unlike most job sites you don't get a
description of what the job entails you
don't get a description of the
requirements you don't get a you know
indication of what to pay on that job is
so you know here you're applying for a
job and 200 characters that you really
know nothing about
and it says well the employer will get
back to you if you're interested you
know that doesn't sound very reasonable
to me and the example I picked there was
a licensing examiner too from the state
I mean that's a job there should be a
job description for it there should be a
pay scale for it but they're not
available the only way to find it is to
go to the state and website and try and
track it down separately it should just
be on one of those clickable links
and then you know the 200 characters I
could say well I worked at a convenience
store and I used to have to examine
licenses to see if they were old enough
to buy cigarettes it's not qualified to
be as a licensing examiner well maybe it
does maybe it doesn't I have no clue
because I don't know what that job
involves
and
so I really think that you know we need
to find a system whereby people that are
unemployed for a long time can get
matched up with jobs they can do I think
that you know that's something that
let's let the Department of Employment
Security come up with a better program
the people that are still filing after
10 weeks maybe speak to them personally
find out how come they're still looking
speak to the employers find out why that
job is still there you know see if maybe
you can match some of these people up
because I mean that's really what we
need is put these people back to work
and the last thing I want to respond to
is something that representative
turcotte said about anybody can make 20
bucks an hour if they want to and the
answer is well maybe and maybe not I
volunteer for a group that is unemployed
Sports unemployed people I would say
most of those people would love to take
a 20 an hour job if they could find it
if you grew up Senator turcott probably
has greater skills than most of them and
that's probably he doesn't struggle with
most of them will and as far as the guy
who is the
heavy equipment operator in the North
country and can't find a job in the
winter well maybe there's plenty of jobs
down in Dover but how's he going to
afford to move down to Dover for six
months to get it I mean if you have a
job that pays twenty dollars an hour
then you figure at 30 percent of your
income for an apartment you need to be
able to run an apartment for a thousand
dollars a month
so maybe representative turcott's got a
bunch of jobs to pay twenty dollars an
hour and notice where the people can run
an apartment for a thousand dollars a
month but somehow I doubt it thank you
thank you
any questions from Mr schweiker
apologies I think Ray and I actually
both submitted cards by accident there
we got our wires crossed but I'm Stephen
Tower from nhla I believe I'm the other
card
I see okay you're Stephen yes and you're
gonna are you and Raven going to testify
together okay
a little bit of a confusion this morning
no worries
um good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee um I think my job will be
pretty easy today I believe the Deputy
Commissioner covered most of what I was
going to talk to you about today I did
want to just touch on a couple other
points that
um
I I think could be emphasized so
over the last two years I've lost track
of how many times I've heard somebody
say well it's just that nobody wants to
work anymore you know people are taking
advantage of the unemployment system and
they just want to stay home and sit on
the couch and eat bon bons and watch TV
and I think uh in large part uh the
deputy commissioner's testimony uh
showed with uh some of the data that he
provided that that's not necessarily the
case and I just wanted to emphasize a
few other things about that
um so the current average weekly benefit
rate that is paid is uh 356 per week
um and uh that comes out to about 15 30
per month
um and as the Deputy Commissioner
mentioned the the wage replacement rate
for the the is about 30 so they're
getting a when when somebody is
separated from their employment through
no fault of their own they're
essentially getting a 70 pay cut while
they're on unemployment
um and that 15 30 the average rate that
people receive
um is hard to live on that per month
um right now the average rent for a one
bedroom apartment in Manchester is
sixteen hundred so if somebody is
earning the average Unemployment uh
weekly benefit rate uh and they live in
the Manchester area they couldn't afford
rent never mind food utilities gas any
other bills that they have
um so uh the the unemployment
benefits that they receive help
keep them from complete Financial ruin
but they are not living comfortably
sitting home
eating bon bons
um
the
uh
there is some discussion about the
individual in the North Country who is
enjoying his 26 weeks of unemployment
each year
um
presumably or allegedly
so as a reminder when someone is
receiving unemployment benefits they are
somebody who up until recently was
dutifully working and earning income
they had been working enough to generate
enough earnings in their uh base period
to establish their weekly benefit rate
and through no fault of their own they
become unemployed while they are
receiving benefits they have to search
for work they have to weekly report
where they have search for work with
information about the employers that
they've contacted they have to remain
able and available and certified of that
and they have to certify to their job
search requirements the department
regularly audits some amount of those
job search reports and
um they in each of their offices across
the state they have big bold posters up
declaring their successful fraud
convictions for people that they catch
lying on any of these certifications who
have been falsely collecting
unemployment benefits so there there are
real things that people have to do to
receive this unemployment benefits and
one of those things is if they find
available work or they are offered
suitable work they have to take it they
can't choose to to sit on unemployment
and not take a job that's offered to
them
um
so given that there's uh only about
eight percent of people currently
exhausting their unemployment benefits
um there may be a question of well it's
such a small number if we reduce the
number of weeks it's only affecting a
small portion of the people receiving
unemployment benefits but each person in
that eight percent is a New Hampshire
resident who has a real life and real
reasons and
um the Deputy Commissioner testified
some of those are people who are going
through the job training program I know
um personally when I was a child my
father had worked at a business a
warehouse in Massachusetts for 25 years
and got laid off and because of the type
of work he was doing there weren't
really jobs that he could just go out
and find another job like that so he
went through the Massachusetts program
and uh went through job training and
learned new job skills and that was a
process for him the other folks who at
nhla that we see frequently who
likely need longer to find jobs than the
general 10 weeks average are people with
caregiving responsibilities that may
have only been available to work second
shift or third shift and you know their
work search is limited to trying to find
work that suits their uh their child
care needs also
perhaps people who have substantial
disabilities that make them harder to
hire a less
less attractive to employers because of
the the difficulties that that
individual may have in completing a lot
of tasks and then there's a lot of data
out there that shows that older workers
on average uh have a noticeably
statistically relevant longer period of
being on unemployment and I think that a
lot of that goes to bias that may exist
that somebody towards the end of their
working career may not be able to accept
and and take on you know new skills and
new new tasks and then there's there's
also not maybe not an unreasonable
concern from an employer of well this
person was recently became unemployed in
their 65 how much longer are they going
to work for my company am I going to
hire them and then two and a half years
later they decide to retire and I have
to find and train a new employee so
there are barriers that make it harder
for older workers to to find jobs
particularly jobs that are are relevant
to what they had been doing in the past
and this bill would affect all of these
sorts of people who may take longer
periods of time to find work I think
everything else I had planned on saying
the deputy Commissioners testified too
so I'll leave it at that if anyone has
you mentioned in the previous week I
mentioned also the the network of
support uh our job opportunities for the
Job Corps and all those other things and
yet we as a committee don't talk a whole
lot about that so when you when you look
at the workers of the Unemployment uh
compensation do you ever take a look at
that system and the benefits that that
system provides because we don't talk
about it a whole lot here I mean there
is support for unemployed workers get
them back to work and there's all kinds
of programs that they're available to
them
um so in our work we do have some
individuals again we represent
specifically low-income workers who are
having issues with unemployment and we
do see some people who are in job
training programs
um
but a lot of the job training programs
that are out there are for people who
um because of the the field that they
worked in or the length of time that
they've been looking for work May
have a harder time finding work without
going through a program and learning new
skills and a lot of our clients we don't
see that I have definitely had a couple
clients who have been in the the
training programs what we do frequently
see at nhla is one of the other areas
that we work in are disability claims
and disability appeals
um
and uh the New Hampshire employment
security has programs in place for
people who
um are disabled who maybe have filed for
disability and either received it or
didn't receive it but they want to try
to get back into the workforce and the
department provides
um
opportunities to try to find out what
the their disability limitations are and
find work that works around those
disabilities and that those disabilities
and
um if I can one more point that I forgot
to mention earlier
um uh representative turcotte mentioned
Florida
um and and described Florida and and
some of the the ways that their
unemployment program works down there
and
um for folks who may not have seen it
during the pandemic there were a lot of
news stories about how
um Florida's unemployment system was a
mess in a lot of ways both the
administration of the program and the
fact that the limited number of weeks
that we're eligible for down there
people were exhausting their benefits
sometimes it took them six months to get
their benefits but when they exhausted
their benefits they very quickly
still were in a position of being unable
to return to work during the height of
that pandemic and had no support
um and on the other hand while it was
certainly a a difficult time for all
states running their unemployment
programs during the pandemic I think
nhla broadly is pretty impressed with
the way nags managed that disaster and I
I just you know I I just want to say
that I don't think
it's in New Hampshire's best interest to
try to emulate Florida's unemployment
program
I think we do a pretty good job here
thank you thank you
so you know other questions thank you
very much for your testimony I have no
additional pink cards is there anyone
who would like to testify or was not
testified
seeing none
it is 12 17 I'm closing the hearing on
House Bill 190 FN we are adjourned until
one o'clock where we have
um hearings at one two and three so
foreign
if committee members will take their
seats please
we're one minute behind so I get oh
three minutes behind I'm not getting
dessert
I would like to open the hearing on
House Bill 232
call the prime sponsor representative
Brian Sullivan
the current state of a long process that
I've been involved with dealing with
public sector ownership
it started with a bill that I filed four
years ago
which would have created a state plan
public sector oship that state plan is a
very involved process
I think at the time not only the
complexity of the developing estate plan
was an issue but also there are a lot of
unanswered questions that were an issue
um
and so uh
in in the end it did pass the house it
passed the Senate but the governor
vetoed it
um
the following session
I had an epiphany
that perhaps rather than just trying to
blast the thing through maybe we ought
to answer those unanswered questions
um so the next bill I proposed was a to
create a study committee to
um to study what it would take to create
a state plan for public sector roadship
and I did bring copies of the report
um
how come we didn't get her around no
holder so if I could put these people in
I I had envisioned that the
recommendation from the committee would
be
um
to create a state plan for public sector
oship
with all those unanswered questions
being filled in that is not what the
committee ended up doing
um and I will say that I'm perfectly
happy with what the committee did
um and we managed to have a unanimous
decision out of that committee we had
the chairman was on the committee
representative avalani from this
committee was also on the study
committee as was Senator Kevin Kavanaugh
and myself
um and in the end what we agreed to do
was create a bill which is House Bill
232 that would
come short of creating the plan but
would adopt the
um the OSHA safety standards
specifically the 1910 standards into New
Hampshire law
so just like all the private sector
workers in New Hampshire
the public sector workers would be um
covered by the same set of safety
standards I remember at the signing
ceremony the governor indicated that I
don't understand why we have two
different systems
so basically this would take care of
that
and essentially would
um
would adopt those 1910 standards which
are the general the General Industry
standards there's actually three
different sets of Standards we've we've
decided that these were the best fit and
the public sector workers would be
covered by those standards
understand though that it would still be
governed by the New Hampshire Department
of Labor so the same inspectors that go
out now to check public sector
workplaces would be out checking public
sector workplaces and um looking for
safety issues that they could rectify
um
so basically the bill does several
things
um it adopts the 1910 standards
it repeals seven specific standards that
have been adopted into RSA 277.
um that way we won't have overlapping
standards the old New Hampshire standard
and then the the new OSHA standard so we
took out the New Hampshire standards
which in some cases were very similar to
the OSHA standards sometimes just a
little bit shorter simpler but basically
we would take those out and replace
everything with the 1910 standards
um this bill would also direct and
authorize the New Hampshire Department
of Labor to make any rule changes that
are needed to get those standards into
New Hampshire law
so basically it uh it allows them to do
what they do to make sure the safety
standards are where they need to be in
in the rules
there is one exception to what we um
one piece of the 1910 rules that we
carved out and did not adopt and that is
section U which is shows up in the bill
and what that is very simply are the
covid safety standards
quite frankly
we had no interest in getting into that
um we we know what a third rail covet
issues can be and this is about worker
safety and we did not want to have the
whole thing sidelined by
um the uh
issues that are sometimes come up
relating to covet so that's the only
um
one of the reasons that this was
necessary is that the New Hampshire
standards were um
in comparison to the OSHA standards were
quite incomplete there are a lot of
pieces that were just not in there in
working with the Deputy Commissioner on
this work we say well what for example
there are no electrical standards in the
um New Hampshire Department of Labor
standards
and you know we asked well what would
happen if
there's a junction box that was left
open there's exposed wires and that type
of thing and the the answer was that
that would be covered by the um the uh
General
I can't remember the term General
conditions yeah
was it
thank you there you go thank you general
duty standards and essentially with the
general duty standard is is basically
says workplaces ought to be safe and you
ought to make it that way
um just in general things ought to be
safe so that's a catch-all that anything
that's unsafe you can um put it under
um but we also concluded that that was
unfair to both employers and employees
if you don't put the standards into the
laws or the rules then how is an
employer supposed to know if they're in
violation or not they're just going to
have an inspector show up and said you
should have known better
um so this would fill in a lot of gaps
that existed in the
New Hampshire standards and would
go much further and cover all of the
various issues that OSHA has adopted
over the years
um
in an email yesterday I did send out the
file that the Department of Labor put
together for the committee which I have
to say they did one heck of a big job
if anybody opened that file if if you do
open the file you've got to download it
first and make it um
uh able to to edit once you do that
it'll collapse down and you've got just
the table of contents and you can click
on the little arrow next to each item
and it expands out and it shows
um
in blue all of the areas that New
Hampshire has a standard in red they
indicated areas that were perhaps
unneeded
and basically you'll see a lot of pieces
that aren't blue
that New Hampshire hasn't covered this
would fill all of that in so I think
it's
very helpful to do this but it does it
does not bring OSHA well OSHA's already
in New Hampshire it's it's here covering
um private sector workers but basically
it does not bring OSHA into our public
sector workplaces the same folks that
inspect now will be inspecting once um
these standards are in place
um
I would say that the state of Maine and
the state of Massachusetts
adopted the OSHA standard some years ago
and then concluded years later that we
think we'd be better off having a state
plan
um might that happen down the road here
maybe
um but it doesn't have to and
essentially
um we will simply have a much more
and with that I think I'll end my
testimony and take any questions that
might be out there thank you
thank you representative just for the
record for people the 1910 is just a
number numerical number in the law it's
not the 1910 year information that we're
adopting here thank you because that's
what I thought they were talking about
at first so are there any questions for
soon on thank you very much I I do have
a representative uh Perez but I need to
um ask her to hold we want to have a
assistant commissioner Ogden
um
I know is he he has to uh vacate the
all right Mr Ogden nice to see you again
nice to see you thank you Rudy Ogden um
Department of Labor I representative
Sullivan did a great job of uh putting
the information out there a couple
things that we wanted to make sure were
touched upon because questions have come
up clearly this is not in any way uh
replacing or supplanting what's
presently happening with private
employers so private employers would
still be governed and covered by OSHA
through the U.S Department of Labor I
understand there were some questions
that came up relative to that the
Department's Authority relative to
enforce safety standards for employees
comes from two places an RSA 277 and if
you look at RSA 277 in terms of uh 1B
that's the definitional section which
makes pretty clear that what we're
talking about is the state or its
political subdivision so just to clarify
this is not in any way interrupting
interfering or supplanting what's
happening relative to the U.S Department
of Labor and its enforcement of Osha
standards on private employers the other
thing that I wanted to touch upon and
representative Sullivan did a great job
of introducing it is folks have come up
and said so presently what is happening
the general duty Clause is a very real
thing and what I mean by that is if we
do come across safety concerns it's not
as if we just say there's not an
existing standard so it is entirely
ignored instead what we would look at is
lab 1403 it's a labor regulation which
basically is resultant from our
enforcement Authority Under RSA 277
which allows the department to say
employers and the public sector should
be providing safe employment and there
should be safeguards in place in order
to ensure that their workplaces are safe
through that we have a general duty
Clause where we're able to say to
employers that is not safe that does not
seem safe and subject to standard I will
acknowledge that the general duties
Clause is not the most beneficial
enforcement mechanism in the sense of
you have to for every time you cite and
use the general duty Clause you are then
coming from a position where you have to
establish that what you're providing is
a standard and it is accepted so that is
something where oftentimes I will say
our inspectors already look to OSHA
standards or they look to generally
industry accepted standards and from
that they try and extrapolate what a
reasonable uh general duty Clause
standard would be I would acknowledge
the department has to do a better job on
safety this is something that was
highlighted some years ago where people
talked about the thoroughness of our
inspections the work in terms of what
went into reports I'm happy to report
that I think we are doing a better job
but we need to continue to do a better
job and that whether this passes or not
is something we will work towards and we
are working towards that relative to
training and also recruitment when we
worked with the study committee over the
summer there were questions about how
this would impact the department
operations in terms of hiring or
additional staff needed when this was
looked at or presented as coming in
being a full OSHA state plan we had
talked of having upwards of an
additional six positions I want to be
clear that we were talking about hiring
an additional six staff four of those
individuals were specifically going to
be working with the consultancy program
not to get too far in the weeds but if
you're an OSHA state plan you actually
have to set up and establish a
consultancy program for the benefit of
employers we envisioned if we set up
that consultancy program we would hire
three additional inspectors who would
not do field inspections but would just
be working on a consultancy basis
additionally we envisioned putting in
place administrative support for that
consult potency program consultancy
programs are a good thing consultancy
programs are something we might think
about again no matter what happens here
but because this is no longer saying
you're going to be an OSHA state plan
and you need that we do not anticipate
pursuing those positions presently the
other if we're talking about six
positions total the other positions we
were talking about was an additional
field inspector historically at least in
my time or tenure with the Department
we've always had two field inspectors
wholly dedicated to performing safety
inspections
we anticipated hiring a third we have
done that in the sense of we have put a
position in place we are recruiting for
that we presently have two safety
inspectors we are trying to hire a third
I understand some folks might say well
that's only one additional uh inspector
but I would say when you only had two
adding a third is a significant
enhancement of the services we're
offering
um so we hope that that that works
towards a gun regardless of what happens
with this bill other things that have
come up as questions of the department
is people have said well you know is
this going to be hard for the cities and
towns I do think that there are
instances in which cities and towns will
have difficulties I do think that when
these standards are are set out there
and made clear
um again as representative Sullivan
referenced uh there's a lot there and I
imagine that there are some cities and
towns that are not up to standard and in
those instances there would be work that
would have to be done there would be
costs folks have asked can we quantify
that cost the department unfortunately
we're not in a position to say what this
would cost each individual City and town
in the state additionally there'd be
added costs and effort that the state
itself would have to put forward each
state agency as a public employer would
have to make sure that they were up to
standard I will say in having talked
with some agencies some agencies feel
that they are there but again it would
have to be something that would then be
looked at
we've had the question come up would
there be some type of grace period or
some type of you know easing into this
if this were to pass these would be the
standards these are the standards that
we would hold employers to I would say
that I don't imagine us departing from
our existing practice and our existing
practices when we do a safety inspection
absent some type of immediate need for
injunctive relief or immediate okay this
is a life or death and something needs
to stop in the immediate we presently
provide employers with a remediation
period we understand that cities and
towns and public employers they have to
work within a budget process and that's
not to say that safety you know that
cost shouldn't be safety that's pursued
it is to say though that we understand
those practical realities and that's why
again our inspections are typically
followed with a remediation period where
what we're saying to the employer is
listen we have identified certain things
that are not to standard what is your
plan to come to standard and and it has
to be reasonable and that's not to say
that we let someone say okay we'll do it
in four years that is to say that we are
looking for them to come up with a
reasonable plan but I want to be playing
that there would not be some overarching
at least as presently put in place when
this became effective those would be the
effective standards that would be
enforceable
we're happy to answer any other
questions again this is something that
we acknowledge it is an increase in the
safety standards the policy of the the
department is that we do and when I say
the policy of the department the policy
of the department in speaking on
legislative matters is that we do not
drive or attempt to drive or dictate
policy we entirely defer to the
legislature to come up with what they uh
want to do and we we will enforce that
if this were to pass it would be added
effort on our parts again we've already
taken some steps in whether this passes
or not you know we will continue to
pursue improvements in this vein so
we're happy to take any questions that
folks may have
thank you for your testimony do you have
any questions for
representative Goldman
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question
um just for clarification for me in
understanding this
currently in a private business I'm
going to use HVAC as an example we go up
on a roof to work on the HVAC equipment
we have to have some sort of fall
protection or guardrail side rail at the
private industry according to the OSHA
standards so are you saying that
currently if a public entity so if a
town was doing their own service
maintenance on their HVAC on their
buildings that they don't have to follow
that same guideline they don't have to
put on fall protection or put up a side
rail or any sort of protection to keep
them from falling from the roof they
certainly would not have to follow OSHA
standards I would say there are existing
New Hampshire standards as
representative Sullivan indicated if you
look at RSA 277 there are very limited
explicitly stated standards additionally
lab 1400 that's our administrative
regulations resultant from RSA 277 the
1400 rules as we call them do have
certain standards in place they do have
standards in place relative to guard
rails they do have standards in place
relative to scaffolding and tying off
and things of that nature I would
acknowledge they are not as exhaustive
or expansive as what OSHA has and to be
clear no the city or town would not have
to specifically follow OSHA they would
be following what we have with the
caveat that if they have nothing on that
we would perhaps look and say okay what
is the general duty of what's you know
are they meeting their general duty of
safe standards at which point we might
look to what OSHA offers but yes they
would not have to presently follow OSHA
any additional questions the presenter
why don't you call state representative
welcome to the labor committee
thank you so much
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is estate representative Maria
Perez I'm a state representative from
District 43 Milford New Hampshire
I'm here in support of HB 232.
I'm absurfai OSHA
I took the training in berries
Industries I even took the certification
with my husband who's an electrician
this is critical for us to pass it
why because this is going to save cities
and towns
for accidents to happen with public
workers
like someone said before previously a
lot of the public workers did not cover
under the ocean certification the same
way as a private sector it is critical
for us to think about this is a way to
save towns citizen towns money when
someone have an accident
accidents can happen like someone say
you know an electrician can get
electrocuted because someone forgot to
finish
um the work or someone left some wires
on the you know
um not covered with uh electrical tables
some type of incident like that so I
think it is critical for us to think
about this bill it's a way to protect
the public workers and it's a way to
help
our communities to save money in the
long term thank you so much for the
opportunity to speak up on this bill
thank you do you have any questions for
seeing on thank you very much
I'd like to call Joyce Pittman from Das
the witness stand raise your right hand
I'm sorry I don't know what Das is
Das is the Department of administrative
services
also known as the state as an employer
a public employer
so my name is Joyce Pittman and I am the
director of risk and benefits over at
Das and I'm here to provide information
about what this bill means from the
perspective of a public employer
I think that assistant commissioner
Ogden made some very valid points as to
for what it means for us as an employer
to come into compliance with these
standards
um
back in 2020 there was House Bill
1171 that also referenced a similar
requirement to comply with OSHA I think
it was more making us an OSHA State this
one is really having DOL be the
um I'll say the the overarching
standards provider but
um an inspector
what just to give you a background some
background on Das we have one employee
who is our loss control consultant and
he assists All State agencies with their
efforts to comply with the general duty
standards as well as all of those lab
1400 and RSA 277 rules that are out
there currently today
um each agency depending upon what their
business is their safety Staffing varies
um I think it's safe to say that a
general office environment doesn't have
the same safety
um Personnel involved as say the
Department of Transportation I'm just by
the nature of their work but they are
required to comply with those safety
standards we assist them we also assist
them with their jlmc which is a joint
Loss Management committee and the
formulation of those to make sure that
they're reviewing any type of incident
that happens and how we can prevent
do preventative things to prevent the
accident or the injury and then also
from a workers comp standpoint if an
injury has happened what could we do to
prevent that from happening again so
we're looking at it from both sides with
each of the agencies as individuals
um
the
comments that assistant commissioner
Ogden said about the implementation of
such a program our role would be to be
reaching out with those different
agencies to figure out where are they in
the compliance efforts to meet these
1910 rules
and what work needs to be done and the
comparison will be different as he said
with the different agencies some are
closer than others how do we get them
there so it's our role and and
commissioner ogan also referenced
consultancy programs those are
consultancy programs to help an agency
figure out you know you're close you're
not there yet maybe this maybe that but
we have to get them to that Baseline to
make them into compliance with that and
reach out to those agencies what we
don't know is the time and money
involved in doing that and I don't want
to reiterate his testimony but I can't
stress enough what that means to
different agencies they may need to have
staff hired they may need to have an
independent consultant come in and
assist them just to get them to that
Baseline so then we can actually take
advantage of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor consultancy program
but there are a lot of cost implications
taken into consideration
so I just want to throw that out there
so that that's on the radar as well
because this legislation when passed it
becomes the standard where we have to
get so it's a state mandate we have to
be there and we
haven't even really begun to do that
transition
excuse me based on what you just said
the
you already have a group of people who
are in place correct that are looking at
the current environment for safety
and they must be guided by something
so they end up making this up so there
must be standards that they have been
Guided by already
and so how is it that
um
how is it that this would be
that much more of an issue if you
already have a program in place you have
people in place they're responsible for
the enforcement
it's what assistant commissioner Ogden
was pointing out so we currently comply
with the RSA 277 as well as the lab 1400
rules those are the safety standards
that are in place today when you do a
side-by-side comparison and I I didn't
actually get to see what you saw which
was I heard blue highlights and the
variances between
so it's I don't remember if you said
it's the blue stuff is good which means
we're already in compliance and the
non-blue stuff is where we need to be as
a state we haven't done that assessment
with our individual agencies so there's
the OSHA standards are more stringent
more I'll say elaborate so
um that general duty standard
what they're saying is is that some of
that you should just know but the OSHA
standards actually spell them out you
must do a b c d it's more black and
thank you thank you I was going to ask a
question and it just dawned on me that
I'm a co-sponsor and I probably
shouldn't be sitting here in this chair
right now so I'm going to sit back with
everybody else and let the um
Vice chairman take the rest of the
hearing
so next up
um I'd like to call Margaret Burns
representing New Hampshire Municipal
Association
good afternoon my name is Margaret Burns
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here this afternoon in opposition to
House Bill 232. public sector employees
in New Hampshire have not been subjected
to OSHA standards since its Inception in
1971. in
1994 public sector employees were
required to comply with the rules you've
heard about previously lab 1400 which
are essentially boiled down simplified
version of the OSHA standards House Bill
232 would repeal some of the state
statutes with respect to safety RSA
chapter 277 and would require all public
sector employees to comply with the 1910
rules so this of course would include
cities and towns as well as the state of
New Hampshire our opposition is based on
the significant increase in costs that
would be incurred to bring cities and
towns up to compliance with these new
rules and standards some of the
testimony that you heard previously from
Das about the need to do an assessment
potentially hire a consultant
potentially bring on more staff or
internally for cities and towns all of
that would or for the State of New
Hampshire all of that would apply to
municipalities as well and while the
fiscal note does reference that there
would be effects on local expenditures
at the city Town level the county level
as well as the state the fiscal note
really focuses on the needs at the state
level to hire additional staff in order
to implement these rules but there's
really no detailed look at what the
costs might be for cities and towns in
order to get up to compliance and then
comply with the 1910 rules
um I also wanted to note that in the
committee's report which this bill is
based off of
part of what the report States is that
there was a mandate on the committee to
speak with Municipal officials to
understand the impact and I just wanted
to know it's it's not clear to me which
municipalities which Municipal officials
gave input and gave information on what
it would look like to come into
compliance really to take a look at the
local level see where they're at and see
what those needs would be there is some
reference in the committee's report that
OSHA provides up to 50 percent of State
implementation but I believe because
this is not a bill looking to create a
state plan this is instead a bill to
adopt the 1910 standards that funding
would not come into play for New
Hampshire in this circumstance but I
know I could be wrong about that the
other point I wanted to make was regard
with regard to timing of the bill the
final committee report reference that
other states that have gone this route
have taken about three to five years to
implement and the recommendation was
that moving immediately on the creation
and implementation of the OSHA state
plan for public sector employees was a
larger step than we were prepared to
take at this point the commitment of
several years of back and forth with
region one seemed like too large a task
to take on now
I'm concerned therefore that this bill
House Bill 232 would have no transition
period as I take it sort of no grace
period
um before the implementation of the
rules come into effect and instead would
come into effect 60 days from passage
really giving no time to appreciate both
from the local budget perspective as
well as from the Staffing and internal
um you know compliance perspective what
it takes to get us to where we need to
be so for these reasons primarily based
on cost and Staffing and these Implement
implications and HMA as opposed to House
Bill 232 as written thank you very much
um if we wanted to get more of a handle
on what that cost would be at the
municipal level
what could you tell us that might help
us get there I think that certainly we
know there would be significant costs
but what could be helpful would be to
look at different different types of
cities and towns as well as at the
counties to appreciate where they're at
what they have for internal staff right
now that deal with safety and compliance
and what they would project they would
need in order to
come into compliance with this very new
set of rules and I just don't have a
sense of whether that input has been
sought out yet to help in understanding
the implications of this bill all right
thank you
click
okay hi thank you for your testimony I
understand you have it typed
um as the clerk I'd like to request a
copy of it for the commission I have my
notes typed I would be happy to send
them to the committee in an email after
the fact if that would be okay great and
I did also have a question it's sort of
the other side of the pancake for of
your question do you does the municipal
Association keep track of the increase
needed for
um workers compensation claims because
of accidents and any additional costs
because of deaths that's at the
municipal level because I know that
definitely has happened that's a great
question and and frankly it was an
excellent point about
if we increase safety rules will we also
decrease future accidents and future
costs down the line and that may be true
down the line but right now I'm looking
at the cost of getting cities and towns
up to speed on where they need to be
unfortunately we don't track that
information and HMA does not provide
workers comp insurance or other types of
insurance so we would not have that
other questions
uh representative Luca
thank you excuse me
so you you said you follow a set of
rules that are like just convoluted
to uh the basic OSHA rules
how far a span is it I mean would it be
that difficult to just fill in the gaps
and get you up to that speed it seems to
me if you're already following some
safety rules that it shouldn't be
you know too far apart where you would
have to spend a ton of money to to get
caught up so that's correct the cities
and towns currently follow lab 1400
which
admittedly not being an expert in safety
rules and I won't sit up and put up here
and pretend to be I understand them to
be really just a boiled down version of
the 1910 uh rules that we're talking
about and so while they are sort of
generally follow those rules there there
are significant differences between them
and I think one of the key differences
is that the rules that we have right now
first for the public sector they do
provide some flexibility in recognition
that the public sector is different than
the private sector in its internal
capacity and Staffing not in its need to
be safe and protect its employees but
internally with regard to Staffing and
budgeting and money there is there is a
vast difference between the private
sector and the public sector and I think
that's a piece of why the rules are a
little more flexible
follow up thank you so just going on for
representative asked you earlier about
the savings I mean wouldn't ultimately
probably be saving on your insurances
and and things like that
so would maybe date offset over to over
time obviously I mean initially it might
be some some cost but I imagine over
time it's going to even level out or
even save in in the long run it is
possible I wish I could make that
projection because it would be helpful
in this conversation but I just I don't
know that for certain I do think that
certainly there there may be some
municipalities who would see this as
positive but I think those would
potentially be the municipalities who
sort of the maybe the outliers who have
much more significant staff than some of
our teeny uh towns around the state with
very limited staff
all right thank you
uh if I'm characterizing this uh uh
wrong let me know please uh
there is there seems to be kind of a
patchwork of uh of enforcement uh
different applications of safety
standards throughout the state different
towns uh different maybe Investments of
resources into that that whole safety
perspective that
so sometimes you do you think there is
some Merit
in having a standard uh for all public
sector workers in the state
that we move towards as opposed to this
kind of Patchwork of uh of enforcement
of the current laws
it's a great question I guess the way
that I see what we currently have lab
1400 we don't necessarily have a
patchwork of different rules for
different municipalities but from what
I've heard in testimony earlier this
um good
um I'm gonna forget it even though it's
been said uh General
this general duty standard that sort of
fills in that Gap potentially could
create some differences among the
scenarios in different cities and towns
right it's it's a little bit more
flexible of a rule rather than a
hard-line black and white rule so I I
don't think we have a patchwork in the
rules but I do agree with your comment
that we have a difference among
different cities and towns about how
much investment they may be making at
this level simply because of competing
budget demands as well as overall budget
as well as property tax revenue and
other revenue and all the things that go
into creating what the municipality has
for a budget in order to carry out
policy
one one quick follow-up question
follow-up
the association
that public employees uh and I don't
want to put words in your mouth
but the idea of adopting a standard that
would be Central that would be across
the board and applied across the board
to every city in town is it the position
of the municipal Association that that
standardized kind of uh application of
rules uh and and regulations uh is not
in the best interest of public sector
workers not necessarily we do have a
very specific policy for example on
Statewide zoning mandates because zoning
and land use is a historically local
control regulated area so so we would
for example in that area oppose
Statewide standards that take away local
Authority but what we're talking about
here no we don't have sort of an
across-the-board policy that any kind of
centralized Statewide standard is bad
what this touches on however is the
state creating a new centralized state
standard and not recognizing or not
appropriating any funds or support for
the cities and towns to come up to that
new State's centralized standard and the
other piece of this there that means is
I'm unclear where even the funds for the
state to implement the program because
House Bill 232 I don't believe is an
appropriation bill so that would be the
other side of this will there be an
appropriation made is it a separate bill
is it in the state budget to carry out
the implementation and and these changes
follow up
the the
responsibility of you I think if you if
you approach us and you suggest that
this is going to be a cost
I would like to see you quantify that
and provide some evidence to the
committee
that in those in the cases of the
application of a standard that there
would be that you could identify
throughout the state of New Hampshire
specifically
um where this uh where what you're
saying is is accurate thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I understand your
concern about the uncertainty uh with
the money that may or may not be
involved uh you know you don't know
until you start doing it and it could be
a lot less or it could be a lot more and
perhaps then it would be some uh
appetite for an appropriation to handle
to address this but I'm concerned that
with what you have now is the lab 14 and
various interpretations of that we're
here I think because of an incident that
happened a few years ago and a young
woman came to us and told us about the
loss of her father and I don't know if
those lab rules uh were there to protect
him or they they perhaps they were
insufficient or misinterpreted
is that is this something we should be
pursuing and hopefully let the let the
from my position as the Director of the
association it is my responsibility to
point out if a new state law will change
standards that increase costs for cities
and towns and to and to bring that to
the attention of legislators so that's
what I'm that's what I'm doing and and
I'm recognizing that on behalf of the
cities and towns of New Hampshire I am
aware of that situation and I am not
here to suggest that safety is not
important for the public sector
thank you
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
next up I'd like to recognize Susie Nord
representing National Cosh
thank you Mr chair thank you to the
committee for allowing me this
opportunity to speak my name is Susie
Nord and I work for the National Council
on occupational safety and health
and if the previous speaker was here to
talk to you about this bill from the
perspective of employers I'm here to
tell you a little bit about this bill
from the perspective of employees
specifically one employee who
um representative Cahill mentioned his
name was Tom Wooten and he worked for
the Northfield Department of Public
Works
and um
please bear with me because normally his
daughter is the person who does the
speaking on this bill
um however she passed away last year
unexpectedly
um and so I'm
nervous and emotional
and frankly a little bit angry because
um
what this family has paid
is
being you know broken down into taxpayer
dollars
no there's no two no doubt about it
because what happened was Tom Wooten was
asked to do something
ridiculously unsafe because his employer
didn't want to pay to do it safely
so what happened
Northfield had a tractor-trailer the
back end of a tractor trailer that they
moved twice a year rather than paying
500 bucks 250 dollars to put that onto a
truck and take it where it needed to go
they used their Department of Public
Works employees and two front loaders
and They carried it between the front
loaders
with flaggers Tom Wooten was a flagger
the trailer slipped Tom Wooten tried to
study it and he was literally crushed
between the trailer and the front loader
and that's what happens to public
employees when you allow these
ridiculous concerns about five hundred
dollars being too much for the taxpayers
to pay
I guarantee you that Tom wooten's family
has paid well more than five hundred
dollars
I'm sorry I really get upset about this
because I know this family I met them in
2017 when I worked for our local New
Hampshire affiliate the New Hampshire
Coalition for occupational safety and
health every year on workers Memorial
Day I've seen some of you at the dinner
we have a dinner to commemorate and
recognize the sacrifices of not just
public sector workers but all workers
who are killed on the job
and we know that most on the job I don't
want to call them accidents because
they're not they're preventable they are
tragedies and largely preventable
tragedies you know what the town in
Northfield did as soon as Tom died they
sent all of their employees to OSHA 10
training
wouldn't it be interesting if they had
had that training before where would the
I understand that there is cost
Associated for the towns and I want you
to remember there is cost Associated for
the employees
there is
very little in-state statute that says
that the employers have to provide
protect personal protective equipment
the way they do for the private sector
employees
is it there
you guys have the the list the blue and
black and red list
safety goggles steel toed boots
um protective coverings if they're
dealing with hazardous chemicals there's
all kinds of protections that employee
that workers need
and employers may or may not provide
them
Town can't afford that maybe next year
so they're buying them for themselves
you know I worked for a company I had no
idea that the PPE was required I worked
for a company in the 90s I was in human
resources and one of my jobs was to
reimburse people for their safety
classes and their boots and I thought
wow that's really great that we do that
shows we care about our people
this would say that the state of New
Hampshire cares about our people and
this isn't just a couple people it's
like 15 percent of the workforce in New
Hampshire
that would be covered by this that means
that's 15 of the workforce in New
Hampshire who may not be covered right
now now I know different towns and
cities do different things
um Concord I've talked to people who
work for Concord they're pretty good
they have things
um sometimes if the Public public sector
workers are covered by a bargaining unit
they put it right in their contract that
they want certain protections so it's a
patchwork and
first of all the Department of Labor
which does have jurisdiction to at least
oversee it that was something that Sam
Wooten the daughter of Tom was able to
um get the state to put into Statute in
2019 however
for the Department of Labor to actually
know what standards these people are
having the different towns have and
what's in place and what they can do and
really is the Department of Labor
supposed to go can you afford to do the
right thing by your employees so then
they don't cite them
I mean there's at a certain point how
much is a person's life worth
this says that public sector employees
should be equally protected to private
sector employees nothing more nothing
less and if the towns aren't doing it
now then they're doing their employees a
disservice they're doing your
constituents a disservice and I heartily
heartily beg you to consider this us a
floor not a ceiling because within the
health and safety workplace health and
safety industry OSHA standards are
floors
they're not a ceiling this isn't a high
standard for people this isn't saying go
above and beyond what is needed this is
saying do the bare minimum that we know
will keep people alive and healthy five
thousand people a year die at work
that's 10 a week more than one a day
tens of thousands are injured and
I've heard of estimates as high as a
hundred thousand a year die from
workplace illnesses like mesothelioma or
black lung or things like that this is
and truthfully it's a hundred times
better than it was before there were
standards so if you think well it
doesn't really matter they're not going
to help it does help having the
standards helps it makes people think
about safety it creates a culture of
safety and all of this builds into into
better workplaces better culture in the
in the workplace lower turnover
healthier people and these are your
constituents these are our neighbors
these are our friends sometimes they're
our family
so I support this and I really really
really hope that you will too
thank you and I have written testimonies
thank you
any questions
yes
thank you for taking my question
um do you have a sense or have any
statistics on what the cost differential
is
um for a municipality or any entity to
pay preventive costs to train workers
Etc
uh versus those in like what the town of
Northfield probably encountered after
Tom wooten's passing you know the rising
cost of um workers comp and death
benefit payouts would you happen to have
any statistics on that that would be
helpful I don't have any statistics on
that I do know that when the committee
that brought this bill forward was
considering the state plan
um the whole consultancy program that is
not in this bill would have been the
part of
the um what was being considered that
supports the cities in town it creates a
consultant for them to use so
um this doesn't have that so there is an
Associated cost for example when
Northfield sent everybody to OSHA 10
training
um there are places that do trainings I
think New Hampshire or New Hampshire
affiliate has done trainings for public
employers periodically I think they've
done some hazardous material training
for town Safety people
um but no there's a cost there is
um
again I think the employees at least
probably are like yeah I'll take I'd pay
it they're paying for their own
protective equipment if they don't get
it or you know
they're risking they're they're putting
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for letting me speak
I appreciate it just pass that out thank
you
um next up I'd like to invite Kate
Horgan who is speaking for the New
Hampshire Association of counties
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horgan I'm
representing the New Hampshire
Association of counties I don't spend a
lot of time in front of this committee
so just to cover who we represent we
represent all your elected and appointed
officials all 10 counties are a member
of our association uh the association
has very strong concerns about this bill
and the costs that would be associated
with it now that's not to say we are not
concerned about employee safety it is
quite the opposite however you will
notice in my letter that is coming
around a quick list that the
Hillsborough County Nursing Home
administrator pulled together of things
that would need to be updated or changed
or additional trainings that would need
to happen just in the nursing homes
alone but would likely apply to all
other departments in your county
governments I will also remind you that
you all sit as members of your
delegation uh on County government you
will see these costs I cannot put a
specific specific number on that just
because we don't collect that
information
we could probably try and do an estimate
but each county is different I will say
some departments are probably closer
than others your nursing home is highly
regulated by the county or by the
federal government as well as your
County correctional facilities if
nothing else the association would like
to point out that the timeline on this
bill is unattainable and we would
recommend at least a three-year lead-in
period if you were to pass this bill I
will conclude my testimony at this point
but if you have any questions I'm
pleased to take them
thank you very much are there questions
yes the clerk thank you
um I want to make sure I understood what
you were saying do you have a sense of
the costs that the counties need to pay
for workplace accidents now or any
higher Rises and benefit costs death
benefits Etc thank you for the question
representative we do not collect that
information that would probably be a
more appropriate question for primex who
is the insurer for all the counties but
further questions
representative McKenzie thank you excuse
me I'll ask you the same question I
asked the municipal Association as it
relates to
um any evidence that you might have
any comparison you've done uh Dev would
show what the what this would cost local
communities given that there are in
programs currently in place or standards
in place there's stuff going on so is
this an argument that you're making are
you presenting evidence to the committee
thank you representative for the
question I do not have any specific data
I am happily to go back to the counties
and ask them if they could put a dollar
figure on it but I'm not sure that they
would be able to not knowing how long
you know it's going to take to update a
particular uh program and procedure
manual that's going to cost time and
labor for someone to do that it may take
you know
10 minutes in one County it could take a
different amount of time in another
County so I think it's going to vary
representative colcom
thank you Mr Vice chair very simple
question do you have another copy of
this letter that I may have one more
copy
I'm sorry represent that is not my
letter so I do not
apologize that's okay thank you
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you I have one final
card uh for this bill if you were
planning to speak and I do not have your
card make sure I get one
um and this is City councilor Karen
uh
uh from Lebanon speaking in support of
the bill
right
oh that's so yes I am sorry the address
yes
thank you
good afternoon my name is Karen Leo Hill
I'm a city councilor uh for 18 years in
the city of Lebanon and the former mayor
I also I didn't put it on the card I'm
also a six-year
County official serving as the treasurer
of Grafton County I'm here in support of
the bill
and I will try to make my testimony
brief in recognition of the time
let's be very clear we're talking about
safety of workplace conditions
and what we have heard is that public
sector safety conditions are not the
same as private sector conditions in
fact all of the evidence all of the
testimony because there hasn't actually
been evidence but all of the testimony
offered so far by the department of
administrative Services by the municipal
Association and by the County
Association is in fact evidence of the
deficiency of the current public sector
workplace standards
any evidence that they provide so far
they have offered arguments about
infinite costs which in fact suggests
that the current workplace conditions
for public sector employees are in fact
infinitely lower than the private sector
in New Hampshire I think that is a sad
State of Affairs
uh I'm not actually here to talk to you
about the principle of the matter
although I think that in principle it's
reasonable for people who sign up to
work for their governments are going to
be treated fairly at least as fairly as
the private sector I'm here to talk to
you about something very practical we
Face a workplace crisis
in New Hampshire in the public sector
across all sectors in fact but over
nearly two decades I have seen this
firsthand that at the municipal level it
is extremely difficult to find people to
work in many of our departments and part
of that is because we expect a lot from
our public sector employees
they work in very dangerous jobs under
very dangerous conditions
we have people who have to engage with
very dangerous chemicals who operate our
water and sewer treatment systems we
have people operating heavy equipment
under very dangerous weather conditions
we ask a lot of our public sector
employees and they have options people
oftentimes have to seek significant
education licensing they have to spend
their own money to become qualified for
jobs and what I would suggest to you is
that this bill is one way to equalize
the workplace issues between the public
sector and the private sector so that
when people are looking at job
opportunities there is not a an
advantage to working in the private
sector versus the public sector because
of safety conditions
so I would just conclude by saying that
I think having Clarity of Standards is
helpful not just to employees uh and but
it's also helpful to Employers
in cities there are only 13 of us and
yes we are very fortunate to have
significant staff and professionals who
are able to work with us on a lot of
these things but in small communities
can you imagine what it is like for the
select board in the town of was it
Northfield those people
feel a sense of responsibility for the
death of someone who was under their
employment
people sign up in New Hampshire we have
a wonderful tradition of local control
and government at the local level but
these are volunteers who are not experts
in workplace hazards and conditions and
having this type of clarity of Standards
helps to make sure that people who sign
up
to serve in local office have some
guidance to make sure that they are
providing a safe workplace environment
for the people who work for the people
of their community so I'm here in
support of this bill and uh I think that
it is not just a matter of principle but
it's also a matter of practical we need
people to sign up and raise their hands
to work in local government and County
government I didn't even mention that we
have people in County government who are
responsible for
Corrections who are responsible for
people at the very end of their lives
it's important for all of our public
sector employees to have to be protected
and it's important for all of our public
sector employers to have guidance on
what those standards should be thank you
very much
thank you for your testimony I I want to
ask the question that we asked a couple
of the previous
um people who were up certainly there
are if there's a change to the law
there's a reaction that has to be made
some examples given where rewriting
policy rewriting manuals revising
education from your perspective do you
have any way of quantifying that cost
that's a very good question I think it
would be very different in the city of
Lebanon than it would be for a small
town maybe
um in in Grafton County I could think of
maybe the town of orange which would be
significantly smaller
um so I think it would really vary from
Community to community but I also know
that we have a lot of really great
organizations in the state and that
there would be a lot of resources
available to cities and towns and public
schools as well because I understand
that they also are public sector
employees so I am confident that there
are significant resources available that
would minimize the cost to local
taxpayers all right thank you
other questions uh representative
McKenzie thank you
in your in your community do you hire
people uh from the outside to do for
instance road work volume private
so a private contract is a working in
your community
and are they covered by OSHA
that is my understanding
follow-up question uh though the public
sector workers that are working
alongside them are working on the street
in another part of the street
uh is that your understanding they're
not covered by OSHA
that is correct my understanding
seeing none thank you thank you very
much for your testimony that was the
last card that I had is there anyone
else who wishes to speak Mr chairman
I would like if we could have the
sponsor come back up and answer uh I'd
certainly
as as long as it's an easy one yeah you
know if I understand that there was some
question about the committee and uh the
Outreach that was done by the committee
and I think if I understood it right
that the municipal Association uh and I
don't want to State upon them but were
they involved was everybody that was
supposed to be at the table at the table
the committee actually got paused during
the summer for the months of July and
August
um we were not aware that uh
well the the speaker's rule was
statutory committees can continue to
meet but other committees could not
um since this committee was set up by a
uh a bill I thought it was statutory we
thought it was statutory it was not
um so I was informed by the clerk that
we had to stop meeting so we probably
would have involved more people if we'd
had July and August to do that I do I do
know that representative avalani has
been um
he had concerns about the small towns
and such
um and has been in touch with you know
he lives up north
um and has a lot of small towns that he
works with
and he's been communicating with them
um on this bill and the feedback he's
gotten is they say as soon as he tells
them that it's still just our department
of labor that's going to be doing the
enforcement it's not going to be OSHA
they say that's fine we're fine with
enhanced standards as long as it's still
our department of labor that's uh that's
going to be doing the enforcement I
would also point out that our department
of labor is not highly punitive
um they work with employers all the time
so if they came in and they've found
that you know there are standards that
needed to be uh are not standards but
conditions that needed to be adjusted to
meet the standards they don't come down
with both feet and start finding and
punishing they basically say this needs
to be addressed
um
four years ago when I put my first bill
in there was a question raised about
unfunded mandates and essentially
enforcing the current safety standards
can result in unfunded mandates forcing
towns or other public employers to
improve to pay some type of money in
order to enhance their standards or
enhance their conditions
and what the department would typically
do is they'd say we know we can't
mandate you to spend money now but we'll
work with you
the safety standards are important you
need to adhere to them but if if you
need to go another budget cycle before
you can put in this lighting or whatever
is needed
we'll work with you on that and here's
what we'd like you to do to mitigate in
the meantime you know to make sure that
the conditions are as safe as possible
but the ultimate adjustment might be
delayed a little bit simply because
um that's the way that department works
it's uh it is not dishing out twenty
five hundred dollar fines uh willy-nilly
just because they can they work with
employers
any other easy questions
representative colcum
you know the different thoughts through
my head one being worked on the private
sector do as I say not as I do when it
comes to the public sector but I do want
to ask is this bill
is this bill violating article 28a
that was the issue I was just addressing
and essentially one could argue that
enforcing our current safety standards
might violate 28a but the department
gets around it by being flexible being
helpful to employers and essentially
this would make our our workplaces safer
but it wouldn't make our department of
I'm sorry
um
maybe I'm not understand that so I
apologize I wasn't so much speaking of
the punitive part for the violations I'm
speaking more from the beginning as far
as ramping up and getting all the safety
gear and implementing the requirements
needed for them to be in compliance with
what the private sector is doing today I
representative thank you Mr chairman um
we've heard a few questions about costs
well
what would it cost a small town or city
or I mean I might have asked the city
councilor but she had a case but
what would the savings be if we
prevented an injury
workers comp cases can go into the
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and if a two thousand dollar
safety feature would save a huge workers
Comm case that's not a cost that's a
savings
would you agree did you talk to anybody
that might have information on something
like that part of what the study
committee did do is we invited OSHA the
Boston office of Osha we've met remotely
but they had I think five uh five
members of their staff who came and they
were adamant that when safety standards
are improved when workplace safety
improves
um money is always saved the they've
done multiple studies on this and they
have found that improving safety saves
money
um and I think someone earlier said
um that uh they're worried about
short-term impacts
um
I think this bill looks to long-term
impacts this is a long-term effort to
improve worker safety for public sector
workers and knowing how the Department
of Labor Works they will help people get
there and once we're there the state
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you for coming up
again and I will close the hearing on uh
let's go
there will be a subcommittee
on this bill and the members will be
representative Abalone representative
Sullivan representative Souci and
representative Holcomb in the
subcommittee I would appreciate if you
could meet no more than twice for
probably two hours of Peter each time to
allow people to get more
um
specific on to some of the concerns they
yes
um
is this on the air yes uh we are oh well
um I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill 150
and call the sponsor representative Mike
ortus boards how do you pronounce it sir
words
welcome
good day members of the committee and Mr
chairman I'm here today to introduce
house bill 150. this is a really a
simple bill it reduces the minimum
number of employees required to start uh
required to certify a collective
bargaining unit from 10 to 5. this is a
bipartisan Bill we have an equal amount
of Democrats and Republicans as sponsors
on this bill
um the bill is important because
Recruitment and Retention is currently
at an all-time low for many of our fire
Services police services and such I know
you are aware of
um this bill would give firefighters
EMTs and other public employees a seat
at the table to negotiate Fair wages
amongst them
as well as they're working at working
conditions hours which subsequently will
make careers in public safety more
attractive for people to uh come on
board and sign up
the professional firefighters office
services and resources that are
available to members including but not
limited to Kia support supplemental
retirement supplemental health insurance
financial support for families of Fallen
firefighters legal support and
retirement assistance uh firefighters
tend to be not become members if they
cannot certify a collective bargaining
unit this also pertains to other local
services in the municipalities and such
it's just a basic Bill cutting the
number required from ten to five now
there's some misinterpretations of what
this does it does not remove their
ability for Public Employee Labor
Relations Board to consider the effect
of forming any particular unit
on the efficiency of government
operations under RSA
273-a-1 on colon 1. it does not change
any other requirements for determining a
bargaining unit
it would not create significant
financial burden on cities and towns as
the impact of bargaining with smaller
units would have minimal impact on their
finances
the current requirement of 10 members is
just an arbitrary number
um part of my slurring them one of those
days I've been shoveling all morning
like most of you so I'm still sweating
from it
um I mean honestly this is just a pretty
basic Bill reducing the number from ten
to five as I said numerous times and
it's just it makes common sense with the
Recruitment and Retention issues we're
having
pretty simple basic explanation of the
bill
thank you for your testimony there any
Mr representative McKenzie thank you uh
are you familiar with the number of
employees needed in the private sector
to organize the Union
I do not know that exact number off the
top of my head I apologize
it's two two okay so in the in the okay
yeah
and
any other any additional questions I
have a question I asked research to um
explain to me when the last time this
was changed and why
so my understanding was in the 70s this
bill was
um
10 individuals it was moved to five some
time in the well I can't seem to find my
email you're shaking your head at me and
do you have that uh
please I have so many emails in my
legislative box here I can't find it I
apologize I'm supposed to look at it
um
because it had been changed in my
understanding and it was just
give me a second any other questions
while I find this email I can read the
history of this Mr McKenzie you have
Mr chairman I would just uh
uh in in response to your comments that
I'm probably one of the few people
around that was in the room when this
was passed in 1974 75. so that's why I
called on it
um in the uh and it was an arbitrary
number that was established with for 10
employees it was there was no Rhyme or
Reason for it the federal sector was two
and uh it was I believe it was the uh
the uh you know the cities and towns
probably come in at that time but there
was no Rhyme or Reason for that number
it's picked out of the year
all right I will read you thank you
um
and I know I'm trying to make this
question if all our rules here folks um
I did ask the question
um
when the election collective bargaining
Republic employees statue was enacted in
1975. it required 10 employees in order
to certify a group of collecting bargain
unit the minimum allowed changed in 2008
but went back to 10 in 2011.
when fewer than 10 were required it was
up to the employer whether to allow a
smaller unit
one last amended 10 employees was
referred to as the standard to which the
prime sponsor requested a return
but there's no other discussion with a
particular number came from so is it
still that
where
however if the employer agrees to a
um it could be as little as two I
believe if that's the way the RSA was
written and the law was written that
would be accurate
um
so I guess they leave it up to the
employee but
ten five it's an arbitrary number I I
think five is a fair number to uh form a
this is uh
would be five regardless of whether it's
private or public
I believe so correct yes okay
back when I represented teachers
um
we would
um sometimes around a little bit when I
get a phone call saying we'd like to um
organize I said number one you have to
be able to count to ten
um if you can't count to ten you can't
organize
um
would you
understand the frustration when they
started counting and came to eight eight
oh I could definitely understand that
frustration because they're too off and
if the law was five they would have been
able to form
representative broody
thank you Mr chairman I I work for our
newspaper in Massachusetts and it was
two of us
and we were represented but um what
would prevent a small group of people
from joining a larger group
and and have them represent them like we
did there was two of us and we joined
the Boston local and he represented us
I think a lot of people do have that
option to my understanding but I think
having a more local tight-knit group
would be more beneficial because they
understand their positions they
understand their tasks and I just think
it would be more beneficial to have a
more locally managed than on a high
level
Mr chairman just point of information
um
this is only for the public sector this
says no you have no jurisdiction uh
Public Employee and Labor Relations lost
no jurisdiction in the private sector
right that is pretty accurate correct I
stay incorrected on that I'm sorry I'm
sorry
the vice chairman corrected RSA 273 a
colon 8 is Public Employee Labor
Relations
any other questions for the presenter
representative Sullivan
just just another point of information
as long as we're on the topic in in the
public sector you if an employer if a
single employer only has eight employees
that's what that's where the issue would
be
um you can't join with another school
district another town another County
um that uh if if there's a job
classification of eight people under a
single employer that's where the
limitation comes in
all right
thank you very much for your testimony
we have no additional pink cards that
I'm aware of whatever like to speak oh
McAllister
I don't know
you could do you is this what this is
here I don't think
yes it's it
let me get it no no it's not if you
could do one of those little pink things
afterwards I'd appreciate I guess we
either lost it or absolutely I apologize
I thought that that would have been
submitted I I I also apologize for the
mix-up this morning because I guess my
name uh had come up at a different Bill
noise okay
well good afternoon uh Mr chairman and
The Honorable members of the committee
for the record my name is John
McAllister I serve as secretary
treasurer for the professional
firefighters in New Hampshire for the
past 23 years I've been a full-time
firefighter in the city of Nashua
the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire is a state Association
representing 42 local unions as well as
approximately 2 000 active and retired
professional firefighters and paramedics
within the granite state
the pffnh advocates for the health and
safety of the brave men and women who
protect the citizens of this great State
Daily
I am here today to speak in favor and
sorry in support of House Bill 150
relative to the certification of
collective bargaining unit
in doing so I want to talk briefly about
the importance of collective bargaining
especially when it comes to the fire
service
in most circumstances there is power in
numbers
when large groups of individuals get
together there is often the ability to
accomplish goals and Achieve results
that would not be possible with just the
work of one or two people
in that sense collective bargaining is
important because it allows a group of
people to come together
through common goals and circumstances
and work to achieve an outcome that
benefits all members of that group
as you know New Hampshire is made up of
hundreds of small towns
most of the fire departments in these
communities consist of less than 10
full-time members
at this time New Hampshire law does not
allow groups of less than 10 individuals
to form a collective bargaining unit
this puts the firefighters in these
small towns at a disadvantage because
they are not able to negotiate benefits
or collectively bargain wages
by decreasing the number of employees
required to form a collective bargaining
unit from ten to five
House Bill 150 would allow these small
town employees the opportunity to band
together
to Advocate and negotiate for common
goals
such as Fair wages adequate benefits but
most importantly
safe working conditions
additionally at a time when the
Recruitment and Retention of
firefighters is at extremely low
the ability to collectively bargain
would make careers in public safety more
attractive to new recruits and qualified
candidates
in addition to being able to negotiate a
fair contract I want to point out
another very important benefit that
comes with being able to form a
collective bargaining unit
that is the ability for firefighters in
these small communities to take
advantage of services offered by the
International Association of
firefighters the iaff
by forming a collective bargaining unit
small local organizations will be
eligible for representation by the iaff
most importantly it will allow these
locals to access a wide array of
benefits that the iaff and the pffnh
offer to their members
this includes programs such as peer
support
cancer prevention legal support retiree
assistance supplemental insurance and
financial support for families of
members who have died in the line of
duty
personally I cannot stress enough how
much the covert pandemic has impacted
First Responders and has taken a toll on
the mental health of our firefighters
the ability to belong to an organization
that offers support
care and options for treatment for these
individuals in a is an asset that is
invaluable
I also want to point out that a
reduction to five employees to form a
collective bargaining unit is not
unprecedented
currently the iaff allows groups of
three or more to become affiliated with
a local iaff
in Most states these three member locals
are able to collectively bargain within
their community
this gives them the opportunity to
represent by to be represented by a
larger group of a group of individuals
who understands their issues and
concerns
because the iaff and the pffnh are
comprised of individuals
who have been in their shoes
and who have experienced Life as a first
responder first hand on a daily basis
and of course it gives firefighters in
these small communities a seat at the
table a collective voice when
negotiating contracts and establishing
safe working conditions
it is for these reasons that I
respectfully ask for your support of
house bill 150. I have also submitted
written testimony in and happy to answer
any questions the committee may have
if you have written testimony that you'd
like to provide the clerk would
appreciate it absolutely
or any questions for the presenter
I do
you had me at first
and then you made a comment and it's
really rubbing me wrong and I need to
understand it
is it your testimony that you believe
these people firefighters under 10 do
not have good working conditions and
um I think I think that the ability to
collectively bargain will help
address those issues if they if they
have those issues
thank you
foreign
being and being the current law have you
faced a situation where uh the employees
drop below the 10 and their unit was
challenged we have
and what was the experience there what
what actually happened in that case well
we currently have
two locals within those 42 locals that
are unable to collectively bargain
because they fall below that number 10.
we also had a local
wolf Pearl was affiliated with the iaff
they had a chartered member I mean they
were a chartered unit
they were part of the association for
many years they they were held at eight
for many years they couldn't never get
to that 10. even though the town voted
to increase the Manpower in that in that
town they could not get there
unfortunately Wolfeboro ended up
resigning their Charter with the iaff
they ended up forming with afscme
joining afscme within the town of
wolfbro to be able to actually get a
contract and that and that's the number
one reason for this this bill that we're
submitting is situations like Wolfeboro
Wolfeboro was a was a
was represented by the iaff they fell
within the professional firefighters of
New Hampshire
and they were advocated we were
advocating we had we had members who did
their job advocating for them on a
regular basis
because they could not get to that 10
number they could not collectively
bargain they could not negotiate a
contract
they ended up as I said resigning their
Charter in in and joining afscme since
then they have gotten a contract and
they have reached that they because of
of collective bargaining have got to
that number 10.
foreign
thank you
any additional questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony if you could get the clerk one
of your
I have no other pink cards is there
anyone else here who would like to speak
seeing that I'm closing the hearing on
House Bill 150 and we will uh
adjourn until three o'clock where we
will hear house bill 125.
ladies and gentlemen we are going to get
started because my mother called me and
said
let's go we'll get going
so I'm gonna hope the hearing on House
Bill 125.
and one of these days I'll remember to
bring my gavel and I call Representative
Mike Cahill
thank you Mr chairman and uh
uh you know at our at our first meeting
this term the chairman talked about that
sometimes we make mistakes
and we might want to fix them and so I'm
going to go back in the way back machine
to uh 2018 to
Senate bill
that's that's the beginning of the
problem Senate bill 318.
and this is where
it was a pretty good system for
controlling you know youth labor the
hours in the school and everything was
working pretty well and someone decided
well why don't we fix it
and so they complicated things but let's
see if we can get people to work one
more a day maybe if they have a this is
a teacher's conference at the school
they have a four day week maybe they
have a three day because they work more
hours if they have a three-day week well
if there's a snow day they could work
you know it's it's just made a mess and
the hospitality industry uh came to ruin
the day that that passed because it was
just not workable
so that was a mistake
we put that behind us uh last term
and yet another mistake crept in
because
although we expanded the number of hours
but a kid could work from 30 to 35 some
misgivings about that we got rid of
night work all together
and there was a problem with the you
know the language that remains where if
a person uh works less than uh or is in
school less than five days they could
work 48 hours and I know that was not
intended but
unintentional things creep into
legislation and so what I tried to do
and I tried really hard last year to
come up with a really good language for
amendment that we were doing before we
did that uh Grievous ERA last year and
that's what is in 125.
um so we Define the the school year as
between the date on which the school
year begins and the date the school year
ends
what could be simpler than that and we
know the department understands that if
the student lives in this school
district that's the calendar they go by
and if they live in another school
districts they go you know the employer
knows that you know that's the it's
pretty straightforward I think it's
much more consistent than the days that
they might have off that was in that
um so so they cannot work more than 35
hours
in a week other than the school's
vacation week again pretty closely
defined and not hard to find out when
that is
Roman 7
where summer vacation is the date on
which the school year ends and the date
on which It Begins for the following
year
not hard to understand so we know when
summer vacation is
and that you know they could work 48
hours
during that time
we think that's fine it shouldn't
interfere with their education
but then what down in the section two we
get down to we put down youth employment
law and night work we put this back
and we're asking that the the youth
shall not be permitted to work later
than 9 pm
on Sunday through Thursday which we know
are generally assumed to be school
nights we used to call them school
nights
um but they could work
until 12 am
on Friday and Saturday which we know are
the busy times and restaurants where
these kids would be their services
needed and that's the scope of the bill
that's that's all it does it tries to
fix the error that crept in last time
and we certainly don't want to go back
to
the 1f Playland 2fyc approach that we
had from that time so that's that is
what I've offered today
and I I know that there are still
problems with
you know with people adhering to the
laws that we have it doesn't mean that
we should get rid of all laws and give
up trying uh there are certainly
incidents I have a few here from the
usdol uh where people you know had
even younger workers that they govern
you know working too many hours doing
things that they should not be doing I'm
not going to name names not productive
but so we need to be we need to be
monitoring these things and we need to
have regulations that make sense for our
communities
I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing none thank you very much thank
you sir
I'd like to call Mike Summers New
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association
um
we're not really supportive of this bill
necessarily but uh representative Cahill
is correct it was a little bit of a
glitch in the language that passed last
year so
um what he's referring to is last year
there was a threshold put in that 16 and
17 year olds who worked no more than 35
hours during a school week sounds
perfectly fine that worked great for the
industry simple to manage easy to to
maintain
what we didn't realize in the way that
language was drafted is that it
essentially also because it said
something the effect of whenever they're
in school for five days it then allowed
it in a long weekend week so they were
in school four days they could
ultimately work 48 hours and that really
was not the intent I think of last
year's legislation and frankly if we
were to correct that uh that little
technicality I think we would be fine
with that we're really not too concerned
with the way representative Cahill has
put in you know beginning of the school
year end of the school year that's fine
in past years the Labor Day thing really
wasn't very easy to manage and it really
didn't align frankly with a lot of
school year actual calendars so we're
pretty comfortable with that the only
thing we're opposed to is bringing in
the night work hour restrictions where
you have nine o'clock and midnight and
really the reason for that is it's just
one more thing for businesses to manage
on a daily basis whereas if the 35 hour
a week threshold is maintained that's
much simpler to manage if we have an
employee that forgets to clock out by a
minute so they clocked out at 901 or
something that's a violation whereas if
they clock out at 901 over the course of
the week we can manage it to its own
it's no more than 35 hours so I didn't
really put down we were supportive or
opposed to but we certainly are
concerned with the night work provision
being added but there is a technical
correction that representative Cahill
offers in this bill that we are actually
fine with and supportive of
so with that I'll end and happy to
um so did I understand you correctly
that you would rather the child be
responsible for their hours on a school
night
uh and not their adult bosses did I hear
that correctly no I don't know because I
thought you said you wanted did you say
that you wanted the employer not to be
responsible for when their employee
clocks out
no I'm suggesting that teenagers are
hard to um
how to both see this delicately trained
to certain uh habits so uh you know
having them clock out in a timely
fashion uh is never anything you can
rely on so it's something that you know
again we have a 35-hour threshold the 35
hour threshold is easier to manage easy
to work with and leads to less
violations
representative seaworth
thank you I think I heard you say you
had some concern
um with the fact that the 35 hours as is
in the law today only applies to a full
school week to a five-day school that's
correct and but
don't the members of your organization
the employers have the ability to
work with that as they see fit that if
it's a three-day week they wouldn't
necessarily have to raise the hours up
to the full 48 but they could use their
discretion as to how much over the 35
they could go correct that is true
absolutely true
um but I also recognize that 48 hours
for a teenager to be working which I'm
not saying all employees were not saying
that any employees would do it but it
could potentially happen and the 35
hours was kind of negotiated out and
discussed last year we were perfectly
comfortable with 35 hours that's
perfectly reasonable but I think 30 if
48 hours is in the current
interpretation of the statute if 48
Hours was allowed I don't know I don't
know that that's really necessary during
a shortened school week they're in
school they got homework they get other
I know you let him off up you know
representative Sylvester
just want to ask if the person is up to
the 35 hours and then they clock out at
the 901 what happens or maybe I'll
misunderstanding it's a violation it
does because essentially it's 35 hours
in a minute okay thank you
but I think my point in testimony is
that I only have to manage that one day
of the week instead of all five six days
all right I've seen your other questions
thank you Mr Summers thank you
I have no other pink cards
and I have two lobbyists with orange
badges that are just I know they want to
no I it's your choice I
speak or speakers what is it what's the
exactly
um
thank you Mr chairman and I'll fill out
a pink card afterwards
um for your record my name is Bruce
Berkey and I'm here representing the
national Federation of Independent
Business as well as ski New Hampshire
um both uh uh business groups employ uh
High School age kids
and as I listened to Mr Summers
testimony
it struck me that even if a
a 16 or 17 year old was only working say
10 hours a week
and they clocked out at 901. there would
be a violation
and so I think it's important for that
flexibility in the event that that 16
year old isn't quite as
uh attendant to the hour as perhaps as
or her boss might be and in most cases
but I I think that having that that
degree of flexibility and not a sharp
nine o'clock hour is important in how
this law is uh uh implemented and and
and and governed
would that I'll conclude my testimony
Madam clerk no question
similar question as before so it sounds
like then you're okay with the cap at
the time in general in theory it's just
about are you saying it the concern
really is about
needing some flexibility
if it's a few minutes after nine but the
basic cap of time on a school night for
example is something
um the employers you represent would
probably want to have happen for the
kids that work for them
that that's a fair assessment of a
representative Schultz and because you
know by having that hard
cut off time of nine nine pm
um you know if it hap if the person
happens to clock out at 902 you you lose
that flexibility and and the person who
clocks out at 902 is you know could be
well with a
representative Sullivan
I'm trying to think how to address your
concern
um what
you're you're referring to a hard time
of nine o'clock being a problem
how does one enter into legislation a
softer time
but by not having that that nine o'clock
hour so basically take any limit off a
kid can work till midnight on a school
night
well I I think nine o'clock is not in
but basically you're saying that a kid
ought to be allowed to work until
midnight on a school night
thank you so what is the penalty if
you're in violation of the nine o'clock
or whatever time or the 35 hours or I I
do not know specifically
uh I know there is one I know there's a
process at the Department of Labor but I
don't know specifically I believe it
could be as much as 250 over incident
can I follow up follow up do you know if
um the violations are I mean the DOL
like um Deputy Commissioner earlier said
that he works with companies he works
with people to let them know he'd rather
fix the problem than then and then uh as
opposed to
applying penalties or fees or whatever
how often does it happen
that you have to pay a fine or someone
has to pay a fine
I I would uh defer to the department I
don't know if Rudy is here no I don't
okay
um I will say that this department is
very good to work with and and they are
um you know more about educating
employers and and employees through the
process but that if there are
recidivists out there
um they will take action and and what
all right
Mr chair I think I would also like to
give Mr Summers a chance to answer this
if he wants to
um
oftentimes schools will have a
requirement or even
non-school connected sports leagues will
have a grade requirement
would would you on behalf of the kids be
willing to attach a minimum grade
average
if they're working till midnight on a
school night could we track their grades
is that aimed
at the farthest okay
um
I guess I'd be a little hesitant uh for
um any number of reasons privacy
concerns between the employer and the
employee
um
additional administrative work for the
employer
um
you know whether it's maintaining those
records tracking down those records
um I I think that that could be somewhat
burdensome
was Adam Holcomb
thank you for allowing me the question
um we're talking about a lot of
school-aged kids is this bill restricted
to just kids who are going to a public
school which would have a typical eight
to three what about the children who are
homeschooled maybe can be homeschooled
at different hours to accommodate their
parents schedule would this allow them
to be able to go and work at different
times it is my understanding that this
would apply to every 16 and 17 year old
whether they're in a public high school
a private high school homeschooled
um but I that's my understanding
thank you Mr Burkey thank you
thank you Mr chairman I'm ready to go
that's fine okay we'll do that after I
appreciate Mr chairman and thank you for
giving me a chance to answer some
questions hopefully uh my name is Tracy
McGraw I'm one of the attorneys at the
New Hampshire Department of Labor
um there were I think two or three
questions that were being asked about
the Department of Labor so I'll start
with the one that I actually remember
um for the penalty for something like
this it would be under Section 273 11a
the only penalties underneath youth uh
employment law are for criminal
penalties misdemeanor and felony so we
would be looking at civil penalties and
according to
27311a the Civil penalty is up to 2500
per violation
so in a case like that if it was
determined that clocking out at 901 was
a violation based upon whatever the
final language is of the bill if there
is any change
then that would be a violation of up to
2500 but as has been noted before we
tend to try to work with employers
especially if there's a situation that
pops up somebody forgot to clock out
somebody clocked out at 901 we would
probably try to work with them try to
remediate the problem with them and go
from there so the penalty would start
out lower
and I don't recall the other question so
first one was the fine
then you asked a second
oh
thank you how often do you actually
impose the fines
as far as having to do with youth law
um I can't give you a number as to how
often specifically but it does seem to
show up an awful lot when we're doing
inspections as there's an issue with
youth law most of the time when we do
have fines for youth law it comes down
to the documentation that's required for
an under 18 to be able to work that they
don't have that proper documentation
I've been at the Department of Labor as
an attorney for three months but I've
been doing this for 22 years and I can
say that I have never seen an issue with
respect to time frames being a violation
so I don't think it's that much but
that's the best answer I could give you
for that
no I appreciate it and can I follow up
real quick
um
so say this law did come into effect
wouldn't it be
um smarter for the
the employers at least they say Okay
punch out at 8 45 your shift goes from
five to eight forty five not five to
nine so that you can make sure that
within that 15 minutes they get that
punch and punch out and get out of there
you know would it just seems like if it
was there they would at least prepare
for it
I have to admit while I was sitting
there that was one of the things I was
thinking about your clock out time is 8
45 and at least that gives you a 15
minute buffer but I think no matter what
time you put you're still running the
risk of someone who is not learned a
full sense of responsibility yet to make
sure that they clock out in a timely
manner to avoid a penalty for the
employer
thank you
representative colcom followed by vermic
sorry sorry
so as an attorney with the Department of
Labor
let's say you were at a store
and um you were being helped by a child
who is a youth school-aged child who's
working
and he is trying to help you problem
solve and in the middle of this and
leaving you hanging he says oh time for
me to punch out you're on your own see
ya
um how do you handle that because you
would want to I would think because I
know I would want to see him or her help
me through the situation and focus on
the customer service to maintain the
customers in that business
um and maybe not have a penalty for
providing good customer service
your thoughts
first of all I probably would chuckle a
little bit given that I was the cause of
this person possibly clocking out after
nine o'clock
um and then I would probably feel the
need to tell my supervisor that I may
have caused an issue
um my sense of responsibility in that
case would be
to probably mention to the young man oh
I know it's probably or the young woman
oh it's probably time for you to go
clock out I'm sure you have to be out by
nine
um and I probably would come into work
the next day and talk with my supervisor
about it
there
there are other people that will make a
decision from that point as to whether
or not an inspection is required I don't
get to make those decisions but I also
don't want to walk away from something
that I see happening
I guess Under the Sea something say
something because if it did happen for
him it might have happened at another
representative Sullivan
I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question so I'm going to
expand a little bit on what my colleague
uh stated in a perfect world
every child is going to clock out at
nine o'clock
I'll use my daughter for an example
and I think the last time we heard this
bill of Roma Joe's uh
owner he was here
um and so in that type of business
we're at five minutes of nine
someone's walking through that door to
get that coffee
if they happen to clock out at 901 905 I
understand that they can actually be
penalized
what are the chances that the Department
of Labor is going to look at that and
say again as people said there needs to
be some flexibility
um you know 15 minute window
I just think in the perfect world nine
o'clock would be great
uh this isn't a perfect world and I just
think that that creates some sort of
problem do you agree with that
what I think
um would work would be if you discussed
it among yourselves and determined
whether or not to write in something
that could help an employer with
whatever flexibility may be required we
certainly would be able to understand
I see no other hands no other questions
thank you very much for testifying thank
you
anyone else I don't have any additional
representative baruti thank you Mr
chairman um
I've sat in on a couple of audits for
clients that own restaurants and
I find the Department of Labor is not
looking out for violations like that
they might say hey look uh let's watch
this or can be careful on this when they
go in to do an audit it's usually
because of a complaint and they they
know what they're looking for
they do look at time cards when there's
some somebody complains about not
getting paid for their time they worked
or something and if they find other time
cards like that
they just tell Leona hey you got to
watch this you know they're not out
there throw fines at people so I would
believe I I the Auditors are I mean I
three four different Auditors that I've
been with and I think they have the
flexibility of saying hey be careful
thank you
I'm going to close the hearing on which
uh Hospital 125
and I would like to um talk to the
committee just briefly
um I would like to have a subcommittee
for House Bill 82fn relative to the
employment protection for participants
in therapeutic cannabis program the
um this is the second study committee I
have named the first person named on a
study committee is kind of in charge of
that study committee I've named Brokers
of avalani for uh OSHA and I'd like to
name
um
a Democrat for this one uh
representative Sullivan do you have your
Mackenzie and LeClaire
cannabis yeah
and the two Republican members are love
um so if we could um
my if everyone wants to look at their
calendars or so
what I have scheduled so far is on
February 7th we're having our last three
hearings
and then we'll be having a few executive
sessions I would like uh in the next two
weeks to try to have your subcommittee
meetings on these two bills
um I do not know the schedule yet
other than anecdotally the speakers
stated
he would like to use every Thursday in
February other than the school vacation
week for house sessions I'm going to try
to get us in on a Thursday because I
know that it works best for everybody
I have to wait another week or so to
find out what's going on but I would
like to utilize the first two weeks of
this last week of uh
January
let's say the first two weeks of
February possibly the first three at the
most to try to go through their
subcommittees it would be great if you
could do them in one two-hour meeting on
these to provide more detailed debate or
whatever with some uh
because I didn't hear the debate
on but as you know in the committee is
very different they ask they present
they ask a question we answer and the
subcommittee have the ability to bring
in people have a more debate amongst
yourselves as well as a debate with
people that are coming in to have a
little more involved conversation it
would be great if those committees could
do that in the next two weeks or so I
will be
um they're probably it'd be great if I
could have some potential dates from you
folks so I could have them in next
Wednesday's calendar because we've
already missed this week's calendar
um
avaloni and you and uh Tim
yes
representative avalani
um I think they're still on I'm not sure
they still oh I'm just gonna give it a
whirl
get in touch soon please so we can set
um so try to it would be great if you
could get that done the next two weeks
please the 30th through the third or the
6th through the 10th
um because we may have to exec uh the
week of the 13th the 17th on some things
we are meeting on the seventh to have
our last three hearings and some
yes
okay
correct
I'm I'm
almost guaranteed we're going to be in
and whether the speaker goes
to
um the 9th and the 16th depends on
so
that is what I'd like to do
that's okay with everybody are there any
other questions of the chair about
representative avalani
representative Sullivan
know
if you wanted to be and unfortunately I
don't have a lot of other volunteers on
my side like you didn't have a lot of
volunteers
yeah
cannabis is Mackenzie
LeClaire
love
okay anything else for me anything else
this uh
Vice chairman who makes all the
decisions it just makes me look good
all right thanks everybody appreciate